[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm dynamic
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
give it up for your champion
is this not some good ass tekken ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
welcome everyone you are watching the
tekken online challenge master event for
the korea region i am here with rip it's
been a long time have you been
i have been fantastic uh obviously the
korea master's event out here going to
be one of the most stacked events
there's a bunch of players that you guys
are going to recognize in the back
anyone heard of this knee guy jdcr you
know these guys are all here i'm
musician john ding chanel cbf etc etc
obviously you know we've already worked
our way down to like the top nine of
this tournament so we've already got a
lot of work out of the way so it's only
gonna be crazy banger matches coming up
yeah i mean if you just look at this
bracket um we're gonna do the i think
we're starting with the losers bracket
uh to make it into the top eight so
these are high stakes matches this is a
high stakes tournament there's a money
on the line things that two thousand
dollar prize pool and uh points of
course we can't forget that they're
gonna be points points always on the
line
yep and uh and yeah we've we actually
had uh had an upset uh like with uh this
player named infested this this guy's
been kind of uh you know
running over people uh since uh a few
tournaments ago and uh he's he actually
put uh
knee and junting in losers bracket so
that is
kind of insane
yes and remember that rockstar
yeah yeah he's actually a teammate of me
yeah
yeah exactly so that's it's pretty wild
right because when you see a player that
takes out knee in the tournament you're
all the i's going like who is that guy
right and then you see after that also
took out johnny to make it into the top
eight so it's definitely going to be an
interesting top eight uh we've got the
winner side squared away so as you
mentioned it's going to be the loser's
side to start things off here uh and the
winner side just to let you guys know
about the bracket we can have infested
going up against cherry berry mango and
then the other match there is jdcr
versus chanel so that match those
matches are going to be coming up later
tonight uh but the match is coming up
for the loser side of things is
gonna be crazy uh you know we talked
about me being upset already there's a
chance he doesn't make it to the top
eight because he's got to go through eye
musician in the loser bracket still uh
and you never know what's gonna happen
it's gonna be first and two out here uh
it's gonna be fun
yeah uh we also got my oil super harong
john ding and saint and bread man and
cairo is it carol kiro yeah cara it's uh
cara he actually spells the puts spells
the e with a two sometimes so it's uh uh
yeah i don't know what that's about but
he's like the best
yeah he's the best akuma player akuma
players man they're just they have to be
all special
so they are definitely special
oh man but of course guys don't forget
the tekken online is brought to you by
astro the official headset and mix amp
of the tekken online challenge you know
i got this they sent me this uh these
ear tags now which are pretty i'm just
gonna zoom in here so you can see
but oh too high too low blue technology
i'm way too close to the camera aren't i
way too close
but anyways very cool stuff you can
yeah
yeah yeah so there's like something you
can take off them
yeah they're they're magnetic ear cats
so you can just
just like that easy so easy and then
they just i'm jealous right back in
there
they're cool i'm very i'm very excited
to have them
finally oh man but what else has been
going on for you guys out in korea like
i haven't been able to watch a lot of
the korean events because obviously time
zones and everything but like what have
you been up to
um the last tournament we did was the
uiu um tekken online challenge dojo
event so i think i believe me won that
one he played that chanel in the in the
grand finals and i think that's one of
the places where he got a bunch of
points and that's where i saw this
infested guy um you know just some
people and i believe cairo was able to
take him out so cairo the akuma player
is uh he's uh he's a really strong akuma
player there's a
akuma versus pokemon match tons of
highlights uh you know if you go on uh
you know their sites and their twitch
you can see their highlight reels and
stuff so um so pretty cool uh so yeah a
lot of these we have some uh old names
and a few new names in this bracket so
i'm actually pretty interested to see um
also what what characters they might
choose obviously i think malliol is
probably gonna
like a player like him is probably gonna
choose uh geez and uh but he's gonna be
like for sure
yeah but we've seen character loyalists
uh kind of switch it up a little bit so
um you know i saw cherry berry mango not
too long ago um he's like the gen
specialist right and uh he actually uh
has been playing lars a bit and his lars
is pretty beastly he's been doing these
uh coast-to-coast like optimized wall
carry combos that like across the world
combos
yeah it's like what like you're allowed
to do that this game like so um
it's it's it's really cool to see that
character loyalists change it up and i
think uh when he was interviewed uh
people are like hey you're not you know
you're not playing jen now like what's
going on he's just like yeah i just you
know everyone was just calling me um
i think like cherry berry jin or
something like that just did not uh he
just did not want to be classified as
like a gin only player so
i think he's kind of switching up a
little bit so we might see some um
interesting character picks from him uh
and of course there's like jdcr uh he
has a bunch of characters um
chanel uh he has he has like three i
think like
it was interesting by chanel is his the
characters he choose he kind of like
mains three characters hard to say like
which character uh is
is actually his main maybe you could say
alyssa but he says he's switching it up
so much so yeah i think that's the
message was definitely definitely her
right but i feel like in a new game it's
like eliza has kind of become the new
main that i see for him in tekken 7. uh
but obviously he's got josefina we've
seen a bit of julia in the past from him
as well so
whichever you decide to go with uh i'm
pretty excited for that
yeah yeah for sure
yeah and uh
yeah we're kind of talking about this a
little bit earlier you know the you know
tekken's kind of uh you know it's it is
a legacy game uh people have been
playing this game for
a very long time there's a huge history
and this version of tekken also carries
with it a lot of the stuff in the past
and that just means there's going to be
a you know there's a very high level of
play right now it's it's kind of
ridiculous so
um
yeah i'm excited to see some of that
these
players that we have here so
um
yeah we got all these homers out here
that's what you're saying right i
watched the video gerald you can tell
them
i was trying to like it's a great video
elicit that from you yeah like okay
thank you you know can i can i ask you
specifically just about your video
because i just watched that horror zone
if you guys haven't seen check out cory
gaming on youtube right but this this
video like your editing style like i
don't know how you pull all those
clothes like while you're talking you're
mentioning something like
about something like so obscure and then
you pull up a clip of like james chan in
a speed running thing like what is that
like how do you access those kind of
stuff i feel like do you save those like
how do you find it
yeah well i mean
basically i write a script first and
that takes the longest like research and
writing is like the longest like i think
that's like 80 of my video making um in
terms of time and then uh and then when
i when i go into the editing phase i
look for clips like that and it's like
um i remember a point about how um you
know i had some friends in toronto and
canada actually
you know i actually have my canada cup
here like i got um a friend named from
canada
yeah it's from canada or it's not they
didn't sell it at the venue but it was
during my trip it's like a
yeah yeah it was it is a canada cup uh
but it was um i had an interesting
conversation where um uh with this
friend who's like a super turbo wizard
uh he won the street fighter 2 uh world
warrior uh thing uh at the uh at evo
japan and uh he was talking about how
like these older games um like these
communities that stick to these older
games were actually kind of more in tune
in line with uh the speedrunning
community in a lot of ways they had they
shared a lot of things in common and um
yeah just years later you know i i
remembered that and i put that as a
point in the video so i just have like
it's just i have a bunch of experiences
and i and i try to piece everything
together you know when you you're trying
to like craft like a
like like an idea or a theory or
something um you gotta pull like all
these little things
and that takes that takes a long time
just you know noticing these things and
then making it coherent and and cohesive
and then the editing part i just have
fun i'm just like you know oh i'm gonna
like do this parry thing you know like
uh can carrying uh you know a marvel
character or something and stuff like
that exactly
um it's it's but yeah right obviously
all right
oh no go ahead what you can say
oh yeah so also i i put akuma in the the
video as like a chess piece right and uh
that was kind of an allusion to uh
akuma's appearance in tekken right the
controversial right of having air
fireballs super controversial
yeah it's not like they put like uh like
another character um like a more basic
character like ryu or something they put
akuma in this game who has like the the
air fireballs and the teleports and and
all that stuff and that's definitely
like one of those things where um it can
be very controversial in a game um that
has so many legacy mechanics of tekken
right so um right you know i i find that
exciting but i'm also coming in to
tekken pretty new compared to you know
uh most people so um
uh yeah that's i guess that's where
everyone everyone's different on how
they see that right
yeah and you know for me personally when
akuma was introduced in a tekken
i just remember being like dude nobody
knows how to deal with the character
that jumps you know because the entire
time that you play tekken you know
throughout the legacy of the the title
you're like just grounded you know if
somebody's jumping there they have some
kind of weird wall set up or they're
jumping over you for open semi or
something but they're not jumping at you
and hitting a button to attack you right
and that was just the craziest thing uh
for a lot of players to get around and
as you mentioned air fireball you know
he's also got dive kicks etc
air options in general is so
um unique uh to akuma being in the game
and obviously the projectile too like
that just the the fireball myself right
obviously
more than just kumahasa but akuma was
the one that made people in tech be like
what is this i don't know how to deal
with chip damage you know i don't have
to deal with chip damage usually so yeah
you know second being that title it's
there's a lot of stuff that that akuma
tour rented you for everybody
yeah yeah and uh and that's one of the
reasons i picked up akuma because i i
just thought it was like
a cheater
yeah i was basically i felt like a
cheater and like sometimes i could just
do raging demon like in neutral just
like see if they know how to just jump
out of it like a lot of technical
players you know didn't know don't know
that they're like this is like kind of
decently like this isn't like the fujin
you know rujin ranks the
right before like i mean these these are
like pretty decent players and they're
right so there's a knowledge check there
and uh knowledge check is one of those
things that uh tekken's a big part of
tekken is knowledge checks right um
there's a famous um
in my video i also included there's a
very famous quote um by uh nin who's a
commentator these days but it was a long
time ago um i think it was maybe tekken
6 it was an older game but in the
commentary um
one of the players pulled out the akuma
10 hit
combo um i think was the second 10 hit
combo where he like rolls and um and if
you don't know the tekken the the 10-hit
combo you know you're gonna probably get
hit if you're like don't know like where
if it's gonna be high low mid you know
launcher and the guy was just kidding he
was trying to like sidestep and he was
just getting clobbered and it was it was
obvious he didn't know his knowledge
check he was failing and uh nin
basically said um you know he was like
screaming uh he's like he doesn't know
he doesn't know if you don't know you
gotta get hit you gotta get hit and that
that that phrase if you don't know you
gotta get hit is a uh phrase that all
the competitive tekken players know
about that's like a legendary um tekken
commentary uh phrase is if you don't
know you gotta get hit so um interesting
that's kind of an interesting tidbit of
scene out here
yeah nina is like a legend like i don't
know if you know but he beat me to win
evil in 2010 he's pretty good at the
game oh really yeah nice nice yeah that
was that was the grand final then i got
smoked i got smoked real bad one of my
worst memories so you bring it up right
now fantastic
yeah
that was a good time still it was
amazing he came out to
southern california out here and he was
just out here with me actually so we had
both of them like training with us and
that was kind of this i feel like this
period where socal tekken kind of jumped
up a notch you know just getting to play
with those guys for like a couple weeks
you're like dude what is this this is
ridiculous uh you don't get that kind of
experience uh anywhere else unless
you're in korea i guess really um and of
course now the world's changed right now
there seems like pakistan where you got
these crazy offline gatherings and these
players that are stuck together and
pushed each other to new limits right
which is essentially what what korea is
built off of or even japan
uh
yeah definitely and uh so yeah i mean
the levels just just keeps on rising uh
in this game and the level that it's at
is really crazy i think these days um
there's a reason why a lot of people are
you know picking different characters
and stuff they're trying to come up with
new ways to innovate their play style
and uh you know get it get an advantage
but it looks like uh yeah we've got some
matches here um
oh yeah africa freaks maui versus super
huayra uh and uh we got rocks dragon's
knee versus eye musician ui used junting
versus genuine gaming's saint so uh
we've got uh
uh yeah so we're just only gonna have
crazy matches uh this is their
like every match is going to be yeah
every match
those matches are all to make it into
the top eight too right so we're ready i
think the players are about to fire it
up right now uh mal versus i cannot say
that name mayo mao
like give me my money give me my money
you know where's my money what's my car
all right
gonna be going again
i think i did that pretty good i think
he taught me really well like that
hard should be our first matchup and he
is uh a ridiculous guitar player he
played chicken uh recently i think too
uh i don't remember the result of that
one though chad help me out here uh
because i think they ran the geese
mirror match actually
oh
uh it sounds crazy right i think that
was something that everyone was kind of
uh looking forward to hoping for
and especially once these tournaments
come back offline you know all these
storylines have been building up it's
like now we're finally gonna get to see
him like it's it's gonna be exciting i
can't wait uh obviously
you know we we don't know when that'll
be but hopefully sooner than later is
obviously everyone's hope
uh but yeah this should be good here we
go first all right of the night top 16
kicking off here
trying to make it into top eight
yes oh that's not
yeah he's uh he's betraying his name can
you do that are you allowed to do that
this is like but hey hey hachi no
jin to steve player or something super
wrong what the hey hot yeah hey is a
great character too uh with the latest
updates right so that new jab range
got uh crazy dude
yep
all right let's go first to two yeah
who's making the top eight
all right
a little hell sweep jack
and this geese early game before he's
got meters always so much dude that was
a beautiful sight that's nice oh
oh are you stepping oh look at this is
spamming wow
you're looking for a downpour here
oh you know it
now for such a good counter tool and
he's also looking for the size of left
right against you you want to size the
left you can avoid that even uppercut
you can avoid the goddess
oh oh my god we're talking about
two bars of meter now
looking good but still with the light
depths hit a little bit nope never mind
oh my gosh the running one finds his
mark and down for the one to pull down
he's on the board here and as you
mentioned he's got two bars meter now
good position for the rest of the set
oh don't step girl look at that where
does life go
oh just threatening
yeah
oh they interrupt again
he knows oh yeah
yeah and this is gonna do so much damage
we don't need walls we can do damage
without walls
that's so crazy you know why are they
giving that screw attack for open stage
that was his weakness look at this 75
yeah
bro the hunting hawk to chase down the
jump pack was crazy oh man he's like
punching his side step left oh nice
counter hit here
yeah
trying to send him to the infinite ends
of the infinite stage
damn go for the wall about ain't no
walls
look at this shimmy up close i love it
super wrong is actually kind of fun to
watch
very fun
good fun
oh okay down down fours lights out
yeah
that's not going to go just a little bit
left oh shoulder plus frames oh just a
downward one to take this round they are
even in rounds
final round game one
dude
the dash electrics pressure is my
favorite
these pokes
he's gonna get blocked no he's doing it
again he's not scared oh
he
[Music]
he was waiting for it right he's waiting
give me one opportunity to get the size
but now he's got a big lead to close out
the game still has a bar to work with
back be too [ __ ] about it but he gets
caught
he's gonna be able to close it out
oh hot fist will take the first game for
super huarang over
moyo
wow for the first game that's crazy game
yeah exactly and that that heiachi
stream they started off with right the
jab back too like he did like four times
in a row and you see mal was like trying
like he's trying to go left he's trying
to go right he's like oh boy this
doesn't work i don't know what to do and
it's kind of interesting because he
didn't use any geese howard counters
right but in those situations i feel
like he probably could counter the
second hit uh so verity because he went
from that and then the final round you
see him switch it up from that string
into the hell sweep so he's like now
he's got a mix right uh and yeah yeah
moe's
like kind of frozen at that point and he
had the meter but just didn't get a
chance to pull it out so
uh great first for superhoro
yeah i think uh i think he was kind of
caught off guard he was like
sidestepping left and as you were saying
you know um with these mishma characters
you sidestep left it can uh evade a lot
of options but yeah i guess uh super
horn knew that and it's just like okay
i'm gonna condition you i'm gonna i'm
gonna teach you a lesson for for doing
that and uh i think you know it's it was
the first game so we'll have to see how
uh uh moyo will will adapt it i'm sure
he's gonna uh change things up a little
bit and think twice about uh stepping
around
yeah we were talking about you know the
gaming legacy game and character loyalty
and well it's basically one of the
players who will probably stick to his
guns the whole way through if he can
stay in this tournament right so
uh we'll see
we didn't expect anything but the geese
where i was going with that but we'll
see if you can get it done with geese
the real question uh because it really
seems like super harang really
recognizes
uh that moy is trying to get that size
up left right so at this level of the
game you already are familiar with
opponents
countering you with side steps so he
seems very familiar in the match up i
would love to see some counters come out
from geese though they're hitting a lot
of buttons right now
definitely
yeah boyle going in
yeah definitely a little bit more
aggressive to start off here
super hard not really phased though
oh all right well it's back to the wall
but no stitching scythe with the throw
oh my gosh second hit why yes
dude look at the damage
what's the mix up it's a little lower
oh we just cancelled that cost of the
meter though
yeah but got in the round so
i guess it's worth it
yeah sometimes he's only like the meter
uh at the end of the round because it
doesn't actually take the meter but that
time he didn't kill so it definitely
took the meter
yeah yeah
oh no shoulder to arms
getting a little space now oh
yo the hell sweep mind game is starting
to add up here
yeah oh just do it oh what
just drop it oh no that was so weird too
because he looked like he was finally
off axis
yeah nice regardless
take that round
yeah um coming back looking very good
[Music]
oh my god that wasn't the funny tell me
that wasn't fun that was just the dash
and that's elected and he's looking for
saita probably
finally on the health sweep
no meter yet for moyo he's building it
how counter it tells me
he'll be the round yep
[Music]
too far
the hell sweeps
yeah he's been going for those nothing
stopping him but here we go
mario with this meaty combo there
[Music]
do it
i think like a lot of people in that
situation are looking for a reputant
right so i think yeah i was like no no
i'm not going to throw a rupee but that
jab there it's a little scary when
you're going against the michigan right
because they can just throw an electric
like oh next thing you know there goes
half your life uh but yeah the
interesting thing to me about that set
was super horn is using health sweep
with heihachi almost like it's like a
knockdown almost like it's a kazuya or a
devilgen you know regular gin hell sweet
yeah uh and he just uses single ones
it's not even going for the heiachi mix
of doing multiple and then mixing up
with like you know the mid or not uh so
it's very very odd using the hell seat
but it's so effective
yeah it's like yeah definitely going
back and forth and it's kind of
interesting it's kind of weird to see
that animation not complete you know
like after the first hit you're just
like oh this is uh yeah but um
definitely i think mario you know pretty
much adapted uh that round and uh he was
able to uh uh you know change it up a
bit and um yeah at the end you were
talking about like fireballs i th
there's thing about fireballs where if
someone throws one you always expect
like another one right it's kind of
another one
i don't know like i if you play a bunch
of games if there's a fireball you're
like okay now i have to be ready for
fireballs and i just felt like he just
cut it off with that jab uh at the end
that you know
they thought that there was gonna be a
fireball wow oh oh we got
we got quaran we got a horror okay this
is his final super horrock
this is final four that's so wild i mean
maybe this is like all he really wanted
out of his like yo if i can just get one
game with heihachi yeah then
i could clean out one game by itself
right after that
he's got some first to one strats
yeah you can do that
yeah yeah you can have two first ones
definitely
one approach
uh well let's see final game here the
classic wrong outfit let's go second
three
oh
counter hit to start it off for cooper
huarang
playing his character
corner position
oh yeah that was a weird axis
yeah
good step almost man that was just fake
character without being pretty though
yeah so scared to throw fireballs
against characters like this
that was flat
yo i just my strategy might be working
super horror
fight
you don't really know what it is i mean
like horror plays it's one of those
characters similar to lei where you
don't really know how they're going to
use the character right so if you
haven't played against the player a lot
you don't really know what i expected
beautiful background in the middle here
yes where's the max mode meter
okay
from the wall
wow
jumping in
getting him to the wall
oh trying to get out
no life left though
gotta make something happen
oh and just a low we'll do it for the
round round three tied up yeah fuzzy low
fairy there could have been pretty
interesting
the crazy thing was you know i'm looking
at geese doing all these lopos i think
man if horang had it jumping right now
he should be screwed you know like
he's a legacy tekken character
yes
throwing a poopy just to kind of uh keep
them honest
but he's in now where's the oaky
little trying to get out of there oh he
just goes low yeah
i'm so surprised
the backlash hits you know that that
move is uh you know as good as it is on
paper it's hard to actually get your
opponent with it because it's a close
startup but
the armor it is set point we're super
hard on a big block gets the battery
[Applause]
oh
well's
gotta be careful he's got one bar now
now he's risky oh he's walking so bad
yeah
oh god
how did he know how to make that
dude
fall the wall off oh there's that
combo
can he close it out though geez with the
bar one comma will kill here oh he went
for it no motor now okay
one second
[Music]
round
let's go oh boy you're super up
to making it a top eight
oh perry
is that a doubt
that's not a little bit breaking
[Music]
trying to sit on his
[Music]
wow
that was crazy dude what a first set to
kick things off your tekken online
challenge 2021 out here in korea to make
it into the top eight
uh that was yeah very fun match mo
making it through though qualifying for
the top eight trying to get to that two
thousand dollar prize pool uh wow that
was a lot of fun super horror on you
know mad props that was impressive that
was very very fun to watch the horum was
great also the heiachi before was
fantastic that was great yeah
yeah definitely um you know you could
tell uh yeah his
his movement is just ridiculous and he
he was definitely being patient near the
end remember he was about to um you know
he was about to make it into top eight
and you can see he started being a
little bit more conservative and in
those moments you can you could see that
those are the times you don't want to
give anything away right and uh i just
felt like uh moyle smelled that and then
you know he just went in and that's one
of those things like uh you know once
once your opponent smells what you're
trying to do uh you know whether you're
trying to be conservative or go in it's
you know against the top player like
mull it's it's uh you know they're gonna
figure out so yeah you know i've seen
that so
so many times recently now where
somebody's about to win and as they're
about to win they recognize it and by
recognizing it it affects the way they
played the game that was working in the
first place uh and yeah i've seen the
time and time again now and that was a
classic example of it right there you
saw he was so aggressive everything was
working he's like oh i've got a big lead
don't make a mistake just just back up
you know and yeah as soon as he changed
things up that was like the opportunity
that was given to boyle to make it back
yeah
yeah essentially yeah i mean i don't
know what you call that like this got me
some kind of terminology i feel like i
need a quarry gaming video that explains
that philosophy you know i think that's
what i mean
something like that you know because
like what is it about these players that
makes them stop when they're about to
win uh there's got to be something there
right uh but regardless guys that was
just the first match you know i think
the next match we have coming up is
probably between two rocks dragons uh
there might be a player named me that
you guys are familiar with going up
against another guy you guys familiar
with in i music i musician yes i'm
musician on equinox now uh but uh yeah
he's uh definitely um
yeah oh you're right he's shown yeah
yeah uh he well he was on rocks before
uh but yeah yeah now on equinox and um
yeah yeah
yeah we're all reminiscing but um but
i'm musician uh you know best yoshimitsu
player i i think uh you know in the
world right and one of the things that's
so exciting about him is such a
character specialist right he's and
yoshimin mitsu is a kind of character
that um he has so many tools he has so
many sneaky things he can do um being a
character specialist playing someone
like yoshimitsu you're going to see
stuff that you don't get to see very
often right so i'm very excited about
that but he is playing against
you know knee and uh it's uh
and he's gonna be familiar with with all
the stuff that he's gonna try to do uh
you know i musician has been the
resident uh top yoshi mitsubi player in
korea so the korean players are familiar
with him as a matter of fact he had a
we interviewed him one time and he
actually said like um he was like what
do you think uh yoshimitsu's tier is and
he basically said like when i go abroad
est here when i'm here in korea
be here
so uh i think yeah he's pretty good
no no definitely and you know i think
that there are certain players who do
better
uh against you know the opponents that
haven't really had much time against
them and i think that's one of the cases
here like when he's talking about in
korea i don't think it's necessarily
that korean players know how to handle
the character better i think it's just
that they've all seen his tricks more
often exactly i mean exactly there are
there are plenty of uh players out here
just in my region who you know in the
region they're super strong can beat
everybody uh but as soon as they start
traveling outside like they do well but
not as well as they do within the region
still you know so there's definitely
something there we might need a quarry
video on that one too you know match up
you know local versus abroad you have to
wait 10 years for that one there's a
waiting list on requests
dang it
it took me a year to do a junior's
request over a year
oh boy
that was here we go it's not like i did
it
oh
okay we got yeah so knee actually has
been messing around with brian he did
bus status brian in the last ui dojo
tournament
and uh
and yeah he's um uh he won the whole
thing
so you know brian's back
uh he's gonna bust out you know knee he
likes to like bust out his uh his chops
we might be seeing some uh jet upper
action
i mean i was thinking before to start
like you know we're talking about the
character loyalty and everything like
what characters need going to pick
against yoshimitsu specifically he's
like brian fury i've done this a billion
times but yes yoshi in this game
he's good man this is probably one of
the best versions of yoshimitsu ever
yeah
and he has gotten buffed
man look at this facing from me here
almost and that's what
i'm a musician with us very big life
deficit
and me so conservative just
knee is so picky about his interaction
they look at that encounter in it
that was he does not
does not do stuff unnecessarily
everything has an intention behind
what he does
yeah like after all that patience to
throw it down forward three that counter
hits it just and he got the hammerhead
yeah that's insane yeah
oh catch them with the float
and not letting i'm used to get anything
started
all the teleporting out of there
my music has used dragonfly stance a few
times here and that time he just
immediately jabs out like yeah i know
you're gonna drag five and jab it out
another combo hatchet after hatchet need
dominance yeah first game so far fight
oh no encounter
from the one jab
oh the wall position
uh
oh oh my god
yeah well that's the thing you get the
hard part but then
wow well
that was that was that
that was insane that was a beat down you
know we didn't get to see it but i'm
sure the wind pose is done
yeah you know on top of brian yeah no
there was another one yeah that would
have been too much if we had the windows
on top of it
you know yeah yeah yeah it's like too
much it's like overload but
yeah just you could just see uh nee's
mastery of um you know his movement and
uh choosing his his uh
the situations to to go in and pressing
the right button at the right time right
he was like in a huge lead and he still
like closed off that first round with
you know a counter-hit knee right that
was like the only nothing happened and
then like he had this huge life lead and
it's like if you had two life bars like
i would have killed you with two life
bars you know that's that's a statement
right it's like when someone gets a
launcher on you like when you have like
a little sliver of health or something
and the launcher killed you but you know
that you know had you had more health
you know it's like it's like overkill
you know right so super overkill yeah
i'm still thinking about the the taunt
up at the wall he hit it so easily like
boom there it is orange and then the
next thing you know uh you know he
misses the wall combo
uh and then he gets if he tries to do it
again and i was like no no no no i have
a flash for that i gotta fight
yeah yeah and i musician is known for
his his flashes uh definitely he's he
knows the right place to use them and
you can get the launch but um yeah we
only seen that like uh like once or
twice we'll have to see if i musician oh
picking the infinite stage we know that
a musician likes to use his space uh
with yoshimitsu through the runaway
teleporting and
shenanigans
and also you don't want to go against
brian with especially a brian of knees
level with like a excellent taunt
obviously right you don't want that wall
anywhere near
uh don't need 13 win hot streak
yeah 13 win hot spring
oh okay don't hit a button i'm just cuz
you're gonna get countered by something
oh no
[Music]
yeah knee just really seems to have a
his timing down he's like yeah i know
exactly when you want to look at the jab
interrupted that's crazy
yeah
it's a
and it's not like he's doing anything
fancy or crazy and he's just just such a
master at
his spacing and
and oh look at this
counter hit there again
counter hit when you have no help that's
so demoralizing
counted after a flash it looked like so
that that was a pretty interesting
exchange as well uh oh my goodness your
knees feeling way too positive right now
yeah he's threatening
oh man
i'm musician
still hasn't gotten around
he's just getting started give him a
second you know he's putting the pieces
together
yeah yeah yeah
he's definitely double right yeah he's
doing good right now okay watch out for
those hatchet kicks though oh okay here
we go
counter hit launch
and that's why yoshi is good without
walls
yeah
knee and rage right now
exactly frames
[Music]
he wants to make this six zero in rounds
it looks like
yeah this is losing bracket action if i
musician wants to stay in the tournament
he's got to step it up right now here we
go all right right now on the driver of
his own
oh hold on parry
goodbye musicians getting some momentum
here
down jab intro
rage again got to watch out
no
wow scary oh he's so sore less right now
yeah oh now with sword oh yeah
swordless you got a faster flash might
be something you was thinking about but
put it back yep i'm gonna be winding
down your old whiskey business
and oh okay blue stuff plus frames all
right my musician successfully blocks
fishing for back to his little poke
patch is coming maybe nice finish
all right all right he's just getting
started he's just getting started yes
that was
yeah i nerve-wracking
that that round was hard spot much props
to hide musician
right just to get that one round the
board there's so much work and now the
counter
i think he has more counter hits than
regular hits
that's brian fury yeah yeah that's true
it's also brian oh hatchet kick
knee here
oh my goodness
and this
is why they call him me actually i think
that's is why they call him me
like
because of his brian uh
i think you know
there was the beat down right there i i
mean what we originally thought was that
his real name was actually kenny you
know and uh he just abbreviated it as
kanye you know
okay i don't know if his name is
actually kenny or not odds are it's not
yeah you know but knee yeah moving into
the top eight right now uh he's big
chilling
uh and i'm musician unfortunately out of
the tournament nice showing no ninth
place
not easy to get some points for that one
of course these points mattering
mattering uh gonna matter because you're
trying to make it into the regional
finals where there's like a six thousand
dollar prize pool right so just get
enough points
qualified to there and you got a better
shot
yeah definitely and you know every point
really counts i remember um a couple of
uh tekken world tours ago there was
there's people really close to making
the cut off and like it was really down
to like points so um even if someone's
not getting like the max points in a
tournament uh like these things like
these places really matter and they'll
catch up to exactly
and you know i've even recently you know
this is the last weekend of master
events i believe but
you know in previous ones we've had
players that are tied and then they had
to enter one more dojo event just to get
above the eighth place point tie break
so that they could qualify into the
regional finals so definitely all the
points matter get as many as you can
enter as many dojo as you can of course
the larger the dojo the more points
available etc uh so definitely something
that the players are keeping into
consideration here but coming up next uh
we got another good one coming for you
guys we got uyu's john ding going up
against genuine gaming's saint uh john
ding insane uh you know we've seen these
guys time and time again over the years
but yeah i'm very interested to see how
the characters are going to play out
here right uh john ding obviously you
know used to be the big eddie lucky
chloe player then we saw some julia
starting to come out of them
uh saint known for the jack way back
when tekken 7 was just a baby you know
now tekken 7's all grown up and he's not
playing jack as much anymore right this
game characters available uh but of
course after that match we do have bread
man and carol so definitely a lot of
crazy matches this is just still to get
into the top eight all these guys are in
the loser brackets though which is just
you know attesting how difficult this
tournament here in korea is
yeah yeah if you if you make it out uh
into the top eight you know that's when
the you know
you're gonna beat so many players like
jdcr uh chanel uh cherryberry mango and
infested waiting um i'm very curious to
see what infested can bring uh we don't
see him in too many terms i've been
seeing him a little bit more uh in in
recent tournaments but um i mean he's
he's got the rocks sponsorship uh tag
and uh you know he's he he's hungry he
wants to prove himself and this
tournament he's already uh put me into
losers and uh and jun thing so um yeah
you get to play these people if you make
it out
of this loser's bracket into the top
eight who's right right there
yeah if you can survive it's uh stacked
yeah you're mentioning infested a second
ago and i think it's so interesting
right because these tech and online
challenge events you know saw the
official tekken channels etc you know
these are still kind of a big deal right
and to get your your name made i think
like as we mentioned we named obviously
you know jdcr me john ding sing and
these are names everyone already
recognizes infested is not a name that
everyone recognizes yet so this is like
the perfect stage to show everyone right
like obviously already beat me already
beat jonathan but we didn't get to see
it you know unfortunately right that's
why he's slipping inside the bracket so
now though you know if he can win this
tournament that's such a huge statement
over all these players that are in the
tournament currently yeah so very
excited to see how the winners winter
break eventually plays out when we make
our way to the top eight later
yeah and um this match that's coming up
junting versus saying it's a little bit
of a heartbreak because these two are
good friends and uh they have trained
together in the same house um for years
of course um uh now they're all living
in their own places but uh but yeah
they've uh these two players uh uh have
known each other for a very long time
and uh they're gonna know each other's
play styles and you know i talk about
this in a lot of tournaments when you
look at two players who know each other
really well they kind of play different
than uh two players who are unfamiliar
with each other right and we might be
seeing some of that in this uh this
match
well let's see what character they pick
first i'm gonna guess julian ganny
yeah yeah you got it
nailed it
uh but yeah saints ganryu definitely one
of the standout characters i just want
to stand up players for the character uh
gary definitely an underrepresented
character that's really good right now
you know we've been talking about this
uh
this i don't want to call it a bug but
there's a thing called crouch level 1.5
uh where you can basically
if you're underneath high attacks
basically this weird state but with
gandy if he's doing downpour too it
could basically give him an instant pool
crouch down for two sometimes if he's
going underneath certain height what the
heck
yeah so it's a good way to crush jabs by
accident uh basically
bye slap
oh low perry all right we're going to
the wall this is a small stage hey
stompson
saint looking for a way to get out
[Music]
john digg
looking for a wall splatter
[Music]
and yeah you can see you know when
you're back to the wall against julia
it's so scary right especially when
they've got this wardrobe space but nice
down forward too from saint here wall
carry should be easy
massage and where'd the life go
oh my god delayed delayed hopkins what
room next wall next wall
yo
what a block and a bow and arrow
yo stay tuned
oh no but he doesn't get the punishment
that was oh spaghetti all over the place
hella spaghetti
damn that was crazy but same very
fortunate that around there
saved though
yeah
chopping away down three oh
oh my gosh okay
this time
wow the clap
forward forward input didn't realign
it's gonna be cool
that's the thing about a small stage
like this right
again saying keeping up the pressure
yeah he's looking a little bit more
comfortable than he was in the first
round yeah
yeah
oh man was he looking for a delayed huh
again
yeah
that was that was crazy
oh there's a bow and arrow coming out
oh
all right final round game one nice
throw attack
yeah that word was way too close
yeah
yo that back dash was so sick was safe
to be honest
oh backswing what a whiff punish on the
wardrobe's always back cotton back turn
and yeah this is gonna
put him at the wall oh he's going to
chip away again how many of those was
that
not enough that's like
yeah that's
yeah that's that's a that's a good move
yes it's a super important move if
you're a gander player you gotta be
using down 403 all right uh and
obviously you know the range on it is
deceiving right it always hits farther
away than you expected to uh but in that
situation right down four three down
four three the forward two afterward and
you know johnny actually whipped after
four two so if you say it was ready
another 402 could have been there for
the whiff points or even a down forward
one uh that's like kind of the core of
ganrio right there uh just the downfall
to the downford one like that's been
like his core moves going back like
forever uh but definitely you gotta you
gotta condition your opponents in it
right now john ding is looking a little
conditioned uh you know it was looking
like pretty good the the second round
honestly was the big turning point there
right because if that weird wall
situation didn't happen john dee would
have won that round but you know his
attack completely stands right besides
like oh free win boom got it on the
board and that kind of turned things
around
yeah i'm wondering um if that's a part
of ghani's uh you know uh hurt box or
whatever where like you know it happens
with the bear sometimes in some of these
situations where uh they'll just kind of
like teleport to the other side uh
during wall combo and uh yeah those are
kind of things that uh that can't happen
oh yeah
regardless though and
yeah
yeah john did sticking out with julia
here going to soup stage uh interesting
that he wanted to pick the stage right
um and go to suki yeah i'm not really
sure i see a lot of players pick suit
and i still like i personally don't like
the stage i don't know why everyone
likes it so much
the long rectangle i don't know maybe
just like the music low period yeah the
classic julia outfit
oh here we go
oh got the wall and the stomp and the
port for three
get off me
to the round
that was crazy
that was actually craziness dude yeah
yeah and johnny you know you can see him
extended duck enough he's looking for
those down four threes uh and you can
see not using as much
so good at keeping his opponent at the
wall like yeah he does the the tracking
move to to keep players honest from side
stepping out
[Music]
he's just throwing out these power
yeah
maybe that's why you picked the stage
yeah it's like it's powerful
it is a small stage
[Music]
good defensive stage here
yeah
both players are so get out
yeah
the downpour three times waiting for
something
so unpredictable
yeah
[Music]
oh my goodness okay okay
big chance here for sane
oh what a duck there nice punish keep
him at the wall
and that's gonna
tie it up 1-1 in this best of three
john dude losers bracket
yes
tied up here uh you know and now the
question becomes i think sticks with the
character so what stage does you want to
take him to right that that stays there
the walls definitely helped out julia
and she's got crazy wall carry anyway
maybe that's part of the reason picking
stage with julia it's like you know if
it's the short side of stage i got it if
it's a long way of stage i still got it
they probably don't uh you know
ridiculous wall carry
yeah definitely in the wall damage that
she can do and the pressure that she can
keep up so um yeah i definitely think uh
junting uh would like a stage like that
but i'm wondering what uh
what saint is going to do um i mean he
does have a jack uh i feel like he's
gonna stick with conor he's usually been
sticking with kanye but um he's not
uh
he's not above changing characters so um
you know we've seen him pull out his
jack every once in a while yeah i'm
curious i would love to see the jack you
know recently at our n a icfc tournament
we had
uh joey fury bring out his jack again
which we haven't seen in years i feel
like uh so it was pretty rare right and
to see like the jackpot go back to their
jackroots uh it's just so it feels like
special almost because
you rarely see jack anymore but let's
see what state decides to do here i i
personally hope is gary though uh i
think his gary can get this done yeah
let's see what decides to go and we
don't never see gary right
yeah that's true all right he's uh going
to mishima dojo
this is uh and this is such a class like
a lore battle
oh yeah this is the middle of the
yeah i remember that trailer uh hey he's
trying to win her heart there's lord
yeah i guess there's that yeah there's
lore
round one might be going to jail win
your heart by
by beating you
up all right oh he's already have three
counter hit yep
there you go
okay no more of that yeah
i let you get away with that
enough times
still didn't find the wall
yeah
oh boy what oh man
raid drive maybe it's kind of crazy okay
just a low
round two
all right all right john ding taking the
lead here
that's got to mix things up now
yeah
all right
thanks going in oh nice block there
yeah
he's gonna get the wall here
the massage and the follow up
oh he's kicking
again finishing it risky business
i don't think so
yeah yeah you can see like saint is is
good about mixing it up he doesn't just
push with his plus frames
you'll be patient
dude
again
yeah they've been hitting
nice
and you know yeah low crushes and coast
to coast right here look at this wall
carry
i'll just say he's gotta get out of
there
yeah and justice is so good
at the ball like this
yeah and julia's ridiculous and just
like that it is set point yeah for john
ding
fight
wow crash went underneath the
nice
clock
there
damn just short of the angle
yeah
this one's a little bit bigger right
yo stay great lead bonus oh
big
how many down four twos
big early lead it's not gonna be enough
if john didn't can get things back to
the wall though
oh they're in a corner saint putting the
pressure on now oh
is jessie gonna try to hop kick again
damn get it out of here
all the classics
wow that was beautiful oh yeah all it
was right the classics down four three
down four to one that's like the core of
gambling in that situation there when
you've got them trapped against that
corner and they can't really size them
as much you know it's perfect so
say did what he had to do there well
played and just like that same moving
into top eight over john ding nice try
from john ding but he's joining i
musician at ninth place today
yeah yeah um that just shows how stacked
this tournament is and
and uh we are winding down to the uh the
last um losers non-top eight match um
it'll be bread man versus caro which i'm
actually kind of interested in because
um i'm kind of biased i i play akuma uh
now so um
uh cairo is a uh carol is i really enjoy
watching caro he's uh he is a top uh
he's the best takuma in korea right and
korea's hasn't been really known for
okuma play because you know we've seen
the top akuma players uh you know from
europe we have super akuma and uh of
course pakistan aways honey uh
ridiculous akuma and um you know um you
have the american
there's there's a lot of great akumas
but in korea it's
cairo is the uh the top player and he
doesn't you don't really hear too much
about him right so he he does have a a a
slightly different way of um of playing
and um
hopefully uh people can get to watch his
style
and uh and bread man of course um yeah
uh he's he's made it into uh top eight
at evos uh he's
he i would say
he likes he's a tier enthusiast uh yeah
i learned that term he likes those dlc
characters
yeah he likes videos he likes the famous
dlc characters um he likes the power
they bring yeah so um he's
but uh you know he has uh uh he plays
all sorts of characters so it'll be
interesting to see what that matchup
will be but i feel like with carol um
it's
pretty much going to be akuma he's
pretty much a character loyalist i do
think he has like one other character um
but uh uh he really brings him out so
yeah hopefully we get the equipment of
course guys this is a mattress event
here at the tekken online challenge i
believe this is the last weekend for the
matches events actually so uh you know
we have a schedule up obviously we're
going to be leading into the regional
finals uh and obviously when we get
there you know this will be a much
larger price and here you see the full
schedule on the board here korea japan
that's where the very bottom of the left
side there that's today korea tomorrow
japan so you can have some crazy action
both of these days and then as i
mentioned we're moving into the regional
finals and don't forget guys online
dojos end on october 10th so submit your
application now if you guys want to have
a doge event as i talked about earlier
you need all the points you can get all
right don't be the guy who's tied to
eight and didn't enter dojo here's the
website that's the one you got to go to
it's at the bottom of your screen right
if you guys are trying to be part of
this leaderboard too if you guys are a
player make sure you're connected to the
portal right you have to redo it again
if you guys join the beta you have to do
it again for the regular season that
ends today you got like two hours all
right so do it now or don't complain you
know i can't say i didn't warn you
because i said this like last week as
well uh but yes uh definitely a lot of
stuff going on here with the tekken
online challenge uh tonight korea
tomorrow japan and then of course we
start the regional finals after that
awesome awesome yeah i i really like the
the dojo system it you know encourages
uh people to make tournaments and uh you
know it really uh you know helps the
scenes out in these places out here uh
to offer points and such so um yeah big
fan of it and uh and yeah but this is a
master event uh right now uh we we have
um a lot of points at stake here so uh
so yeah
yeah and it's going to affect how people
play in the
future tournaments uh especially as it
winds down so um you know make sure to
follow this tekken online challenge
uh 2021.
exactly and you know the points right
like these making top eight here it's
almost like you get so many points that
if your region didn't have a lot of dojo
events the topic of the tournament
basically becomes the regional final so
you know depending on how many dojo
events you had and how popular region is
with dojo events uh this event by itself
is just grand right like you need these
points and you need to place as high as
you can so you can get the majority
share of these points
but regardless right now you know the
winner side is looking crazy we're
trying to round out to lose side of the
bracket uh let me take a look one more
time right yeah i think this is
literally the last one the winner of
this match between brad manicaro will be
going up against saint in the loser's
bracket since he qualified uh moyle will
be going up against knee later today in
this top eight which is crazy nice
nice exactly that's just the loser side
of our topic right on the windows side
we haven't seen these guys yet we still
have you know infested we were talking
about going up against cherry berry
mango here is the bracken boob uh as you
mentioned confess to terry barry mango
on the winner's side plus
jdcr going up against chanel uh which is
such a classic cool matchup i can't wait
to see those matches go down
yes
yeah so as you can see there's one spot
uh vacant right now and that will be the
winner of this next match that we're
going into but uh yeah whatever happens
whoever wins is this top eight is going
to be
stacked
uh yeah and and it's it's an interesting
mix i mean i know it's only one region
it's korea right but um you know we do
have uh
uh we have infested i'm actually like
i'm actually really interested
in seeing seeing him again because uh
uh
yeah the last tournament that he was at
ui uh the dojo event i think he made
like a
fourth or fifth or something and and uh
just to see seeing his performance now
makes me really curious
you know i i'm yeah definitely my
interest is peak
you mentioned his characters earlier i
think he said fakamrom and
uh yeah i think he he actually busted
out a negan at one point so um actually
like i really enjoy watching negan play
um he's not you know at the highest
levels he's not the most common uh
character we saw me like bust him out at
the exhibition uh against the
gobi that one tournament yeah yeah but
um but yeah it's just it's kind of fun
to watch uh some of these characters uh
you know in something like the top eight
in a very stacked event
like this yeah it's definitely possible
negan uh one of those characters that
we've seen a little bit more use out of
lately in north america at least from a
couple players so it's been interesting
because it's he's definitely one of the
characters that nobody was really using
and you know knee using that exhibition
you mentioned and everyone's like oh wow
negan really and it didn't work out i
don't know if i remember correctly uh
but i was like oh maybe there's
potential there maybe not probably not
and you know it just wasn't as clear
what the potential what the character
was but season over season they gave a
couple of changes and you're like wait a
second uh he's a little bit safer now
he's got another low option it's really
good it's like oh okay uh maybe this
character is actually better than we're
expecting it to be so it's definitely
one of those cases where this character
could come out to play but coming up
next we do have red man and carol you
said red man one of those players who
likes to use the dlc characters let's
see which one he tries to go with here
i'm hoping for lydia uh you know the
character variety in tekken tournaments
these days is just ridiculously awesome
yeah oh boy even better got a classic
actually man i know everyone hates him
but dude look you're going to get to
kuma you really going to complain about
leroy like i don't know
pick pick the lesser of two evils here
right uh but no seriously i do love
leroy he's actually uh my secondary
character now in this game i don't get
to play him as much but i do really
enjoy him
you know both these characters have
gotten their fair share of nerfs so uh
but very strong characters both of them
still uh
this should be very interesting caro
top uh a cool player in korea
plays on a button
controller
oh okay
yes very nice but let's see carol versus
bread man here uh and this you know it's
awesome a match but i haven't really
seen it but launch that wow with the 442
interesting choice
boom
one wall down do we get another yeah
oh my god oh
yeah choose the keeper just get the
damage
you know that's exactly pretty good
there's no meter for akuma yet so even
if you got the jab punish on it you
wouldn't got a combo so not a bad risk
there
beautiful duck on the high get the wild
standing too
and carol not really getting anything
started
the parries too
yeah
he was
walls just keep the damage you know
leroy when you get up at the wall
exactly really risky for 50-50 so
keeping the wall not a bad choice in
general
oh he got he had no combo
he didn't believe he didn't believe was
gonna hit
[Music]
youtube channel
[Music]
all right bread man though
10 seconds
there
your orbital is no good sir we're
getting the wall get that wall carry
oh
short not quite
so dangerous yeah back to trying to get
the counter hitter something
[Music]
oh that big width he's been whipping
those orbitals
yeah rageball for bread man you're
supposed to drive no more rage
oh
dive kick there okay oh sweet living
though
oh
oh man i didn't see that was a parry
that was crazy
yeah it's just perry out of his hermes
dance there using that attack uh sabaccy
perry very nicely done yeah uh man that
was a crazy game dude bread man with the
leroy
very very good of the character
obviously uh but so good against akuma
specifically right like you saw the size
of just red fireball uh and everything
was just ready defensively there uh but
carol you saw the execution of the
combos and you know just understanding
how much meter and damage he needed with
the kicker totally in the kuma expert
that was very crazy for his game
yeah i mean you know that situation i
mean there are very few akuma players in
the world that can you know read that
situation and then be like okay i'm
going to make this combo kill from this
from here and then i'm not going to use
a bar and you know i'm just like it was
so optimal it's ridiculous and uh and
that's the thing i think for bread man
he just has to not let carol get
anything started because once you let
akuma a party you know it's it's lights
out so
uh bread man has been doing that pretty
well taming the lion but we'll have to
see uh if if he can contain him
essentially
yeah and you know the thing about that's
interesting about this match up to me
right is that akuma you know he wants to
use a down three you know he wants use
his down four
uh and leroy has this amazing orbital
heel you know so like i'm if i'm a leroy
player i'm salivating at the thought of
trying to hit this orbital heel but yeah
at the same time it goes both ways they
know you want throughout the orbital
it's easily punishable
uh so it's pretty easy
yeah
uh nullifying akuma's lows is uh really
good against him
for sure
damn what a bad three just caught him
coming in and a couple times you know
he's done this right bread man he caught
him with the four four two two earlier
uh this time with that back three so
he's just kind of timing carol's
approach
yeah and there's that back to counter
hit that he was looking for in the early
earlier
oh
that's the micro side step there to
optimize this combo back to
that look at that oh didn't kill back
yeah that's crazy oh he's looking for
that but he's he doesn't want to get
poked
[Music]
oh he'll sleep
oh
nice jump oh
dude if that if he had her was that low
counter back turned i think the internet
would have exploded
oh and the orbital finally gets it
and the wall
oh
carrot life deficit here
still doing the back too
oh empty jump here okay even flip palm
done that a couple times now
oh man little it's like a little timid
oh god we just got it with a y rising
too
and his full bar what's he gonna do for
this combo
whatever he wants and no meters
he knows how to save meter he is
a thrifty meter user
[Music]
oh a huge like that's it for carol now
he's gonna have to do something but he
can if anyone can do it
yeah ben manning to get away from the
wall
because right now he's been backdashing
the down threes that's him he got the
block on it oh my he blocked everything
he
that time
carol in trouble here
red man how's it going they get hit with
the orbital orbitals looking like bread
man
i'm gonna run away with it oh it's a
sliver of life it's gonna be so hard oh
and just a jab try the running three the
bread man new there
yo that round
so important there red man looking to
close down go in the top eight
backwards with the train
not a good trade for caro
doesn't find the low hit
oh sweet very gutsy
oh i got a sweep too red man mine's
better
full meter though akuma yeah
he doesn't get it doesn't get working
everything oh leave oh oh
kill him oh
yes you have rage here what's he gonna
do
getting that
[Music]
kane oh is that gonna hit her
no no no
oh he blocked a clutch block of the load
oh my god
fireball
carol
and this is why
akuma is so controversial
bro
that was crazy yeah bread man thought he
had the read with just the rage art but
both of us were like is that gonna hit
because it was one of those situations
you know it doesn't look quite right
he's too high in the air you know and it
just missed and that was such a big
opportunity there and carol capitalized
off it that was beautiful that was a
crazy comeback you know he spent both
bars right he was like i have full meter
here i can make it come back to goomba
spend both bars doesn't get anything
gets it down for two doesn't believe in
twin pistons though it's like dude you
had three opportunities there all of
them are gone now and still wins the
entire thing yeah i'm pretty sure we
didn't see the game used from man that
game
yeah i thought um in that tense moment
he was uh you know ready to bust out
that cane right because he can only use
it once and he hadn't used it um but
yeah but red man's defense was crazier
and it shows like how ready he is
against akuma that one
interaction where he basically akuma's
doing the down three fireball combo to
cancel and then afterwards after he
blocked all that he blocked the downford
one two combo uh string and and got
yeah it's like you passed like like
all five tests and got the money exactly
so
man is so ready
very very but this time we're going to
forgotten realm here uh definitely a
good stage for leo with his combos
but we'll see what happens here this
should be a crazy one you know i think
we've had what two two or three sets so
far man but i feel like his final final
round every single time
yes yes
oh man this is a the stage can get kind
of crazy
starts off with starting off
sending a message
first time we've seen that where you
sidestep it
back there that was kind of
yeah
oh
first round
i guess try to keep him off guard or
something or maybe he's definitely
thinking about the last game
it could be right oh and that's part of
the reason he's still going to stay
yeah
oh carol trying to get out of here
yeah that one one string you know even
if you're ducking the second hit the
rest of it's still a natural combo
uh so very good string from leroy
oh the down
jab gets low parry bread man
oh you saw one two there
[Music]
carol being a bit more careful
he does have a bar yeah
i feel like bread man's also doing the
same
yeah he's got a bar i got to be careful
yeah
they're both like we know
your character is good
i feel like you know at the range that
bread man has been playing he's been
back dashing a lot of these down threes
and like he's been hitting him with just
the tip right i feel like we back dash
into orbital like he'll be relatively
safe i still might clip up yeah a nice
catch here from carol walls here too
yeah
this is uh starting off with a 10 frame
punish here one oh my gosh kuma's
strength oh blocks the overhead but time
is running out
yeah but five four seconds of the
eternity
oh looking for something oh just goes
down yeah that was a risky doubting low
parry rage art there that was that was
catches him in the air
blow combo gonna be scaled a bit but
he's gonna go downstairs so
we're at the bottom floor now
oh my god oh my god
wow all right set point for carol now
bring it all the way back the first game
was so dominant from bread man too
oh man
so tense right now back to
oh looking for an orbital trying to
catch one of those down threes kill him
he had the damage right for him could
have done a double of his own punish but
doesn't find it
with the blocks though how many blocks
on the low
both of these guys dude
yeah
and we're going to the final final round
you know it here we go bread man carol
sidewalk to the back oh big punish on
the demon flip
oh i can't believe you went to the wall
he had gone for it the whole time yeah
this is not good for carol breadman not
even touched
working on a person and there's no meter
what a block oh he's gonna have one one
chance oh
only a little bit of health left can he
even survive this three oh
my god
oh no oh boy
gets punished that was that was crazy
oh man
that went from like zero to 100 real
fast you know like like yeah red man's
got it total control no issue and then
also
and then but
bread man has blocked almost all of his
down threes it's crazy even in that
situation where he was all was about to
make that comeback uh you know and that
he still was blocking he blocked that
down three and it's like you know if if
at that moment he decided to do like
downpour two one a mid launcher or or
whatever it's anything it's so risky why
don't we give it like you know
yeah so um but i mean it's new just new
definitely you know so carol with that
sick akuma unfortunately out of the
tournament ninth uh but redman will be
moving on to our top eight here
uh that liro is looking good here is the
bracket for you guys this is the match
is still to come
right we got infested cherry berry mango
with a jdcr chanel but now i lose
bracket all filled in we got saint
versus bread man and mario versus me was
that pretty good if i can't say his name
david that was actually really good
yeah no you got him good i say 10 out of
10 turning korean perfect all right dude
moving on up in the world all right i'm
a fan of myself
um
boy
uh that was crazy every match we've had
so far has been down to the wire uh and
been so fun to watch hope you guys in
the chat are having a good time too
these are crazy matches
uh and you know we're not we just now
got into the top eight
uh dude this is this is wild very fun
tournament so far
yeah yeah all these all these matches
are are having crazy so far uh you know
we've got some final final rounds and
uh
yeah it's an animal
uh we haven't even seen uh some players
these people awaiting winners even play
yet right so uh we haven't seen uh you
know uh jdc our chanel uh chair very
mango infested um so starting this top
eight you know this is this is where we
get to see uh all these players play
and uh
yeah
yeah a lot more good ass tekken coming
your way is what i'm hearing right uh
and if you guys drinks a good ass tech
we got some shirts for you we got some
nina williams good ass tekken king
martial off paul phoenix the king and
the martial ones now back in stock
obviously they all sold out before we
also got some cute ass tech interview
nina anna leroy sugar king arm king and
julia tank chilling by herself if you
guys are interested in these shirts make
sure you guys check out 10-0 gg slash
merch that's where you can find all of
them uh the qr code is on screen we'll
show that to you again later so you guys
can find it uh but we do have to take a
short break guys after we show you these
six socials because we got these places
you guys got to go follow bandannanco
esports bne esports on twitter and
youtube we also got tekken on twitter
on twitch and on facebook as well make
sure you guys go follow them that's we
can get all your tech information plus
all of your esports tekken related
content like clips from all these
tournaments
all right but we do have to take a short
break guys top eight gonna be incoming
don't go anywhere tekken online
challenge 2021 for korea we'll be back
after this break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
arrive to destination
[Music]
enemy reinforcements check your radars
so
[Music]
monster
[Music]
i fought all types of fighters in my
time
but who knows what other crazy strong
guys are still out there
now to get stronger than ever before
i've had enough now i'm mad frieza i'm
not gonna lie it's tense times like
these that really get me pumped for a
[ __ ] honey
but what i do know is that i'd like to
avoid fighting if i can and just let him
go later you guys i hope you're reborn
as someone good this time
[Music]
i can't wait to find out
thank you
welcome back you're watching the tekken
online challenge master event for the
korea region i'm here with rip
uh we just saw a couple of trailers uh
for a couple games uh ace combat seven
and uh there's a the new dragon ball
game uh for this garage i believe yeah
and uh yeah i mean uh i guess this is a
ace combat series i'm i'm not too
familiar with the
ace combat series fly around shoot stuff
you know it sounds like a lot of fun
yeah yeah it looks like kind of like
arcade action uh yeah yeah and uh i
found out i think only i think maybe
from juno i think i found out that
there's a campaign in that game yeah so
there's actually like a full story mode
where you know there's characters and
npcs you me or whatever i had no idea so
i was like dude this is actually might
be up my alley i might check this out so
ace combat check it out more content
coming for you guys but of course right
now we have the tekken online challenge
2021 for korea right now which is
brought to you by astro the official
headset and mix amp of the technology
challenge 2021 a huge shout out to
asheville for always supporting
everything all things tekken um and i've
got these sick ear tags now look at this
move speaker tags i should call my ear
tag they're not really sticking my ears
just one of my speakers uh but
definitely very cool uh for after show
support to us as always but we are into
our top eight now guys we're gonna be
kicking it off we got some great stuff
here is the bracket as we've been
talking about infested making waves here
at this tournament you know upsets on
knee and john ding to make it here on
the winner side of the bracket did not
have an easy patch by any means gonna be
going up against cherry barry mango who
you know we've talked about earlier also
has a lars now in addition to that gin
uh and then we've got jdcr
going up against chanel classic match
but of course things a little bit
different now if you guys were watching
the tech world tour in the past you know
jdr was primarily like a dragon off
player then he was like maybe sometimes
a height well now he's got an armor
thing and a [ __ ] rom in addition to
those other characters right and chanel
you know he's still got the zafina the
elisa the eliza maybe some julia you
don't really know right but that's
definitely going to be a great match to
watch and of course we just rounded up
our loser's side of the bracket saint
can be going up against bread man and
moyle gonna be going up against me that
is a crazy loser bracket let me tell you
uh and of course it's only gonna get
uglier once the guys from the winter
sides of things lose and make their way
down there as well stack tournament
yeah definitely and uh you know these uh
these winners matches we haven't really
seen any of these players play yet right
so we're gonna get to see uh what they
have um these losers uh matches well
these players we saw how hard they
fought to get up here and uh and so yeah
definitely i'm i just i just kind of
want to see uh some of these winners
players and actually you see their names
in the brackets just waiting there and
uh
and so yeah finally um yeah i'm ready
for this
yes this is the stage right the stage is
set uh it's time right now like we're
gonna find out
uh what infested brings to the table
here like when everyone's watching right
obviously upset me upset john ding right
but that that was off stream you know
there wasn't as much pressure you didn't
have like you know 10 000 people
watching you perform this is a different
level all these other guys they've all
kind of been here before they've had
this pressure of being on stream and
seeing everyone watch them compete at
this level but here we go winner side
top a tekken online challenge for korea
2021
infested gonna be going up
against cbm and it's going to be the gin
going up against infested's [ __ ] mom
okay
yes and this is uh the [ __ ] rum that
made into top eight in the last uh dojo
tournament
uh we'll see uh what what infest it has
he does uh he does also have a negan so
he could switch to that
still first to two that's the three
and uh we got
cherry bear mangoes gin round one
character yeah this is great
i think jen is you know despite you know
doing so well in these tournaments
around the world still a character that
everyone kind of does not expect is very
good like yeah no no you mean devil jin
right that's the one to test here
yeah yeah
oh
it's blocked there on the down back four
cool another block on the low infested
slow start nice trade
they're kind of feeling each other out
right now down forward one four
definitely
wow wow and he tried for the big one
yeah
yeah he went for it
cherry mango in rage
[Applause]
punishing electrics
gotta be fast and with that back one
right like that that pokemon back one is
so good it's like minus 15 on block i
think but it's
so fast you don't ever think it's that
punishable
yeah
look out nice
okay
cherry berry mango one of the best gym
players out there
nice duck there
it's the wall splat
big damage here infested looking
like he's gonna take this round oh
pressure
looking for a 4-4 counter hit or
something
damn 3-1 it's gonna do it again
oh running three plus frames oh
still looking like him he's trying to
find his groove here
and that forward four is very long but
oh man
yeah and infest is just showing off
akumaram's range
yeah that's the specialty of the
character right in addition to his like
guards the guard breaks at the wall
etcetera yeah and yeah this started off
pretty good cbm was looking pretty sharp
you know yeah the pairing of the can can
yeah and i started thinking of that mom
like dude maybe
maybe this character is good against all
of them characters right
funny stereo yep time though
yeah they're keeping it really slow
careful
oh okay that's
now it's gonna be hard to come in three
seconds left oh just yeah
yeah couldn't really
do much after that looking for hail mary
ray i i just i just think investor just
shut them out it's like no you don't get
to play the problem
the end of that round though was you
know cbm ducked the high in the string
and he did nothing like in that
situation time's winding down if you're
going to commit to a duck you got to be
ready you know to hit a button afterward
there's only three seconds on the clock
if he had just done while standing two
rage art he probably winged that round
continuing
uh you know so
that was a a huge mistake at the end but
overall you know there's just very good
space control coming out of uh infested
and you know you're not really seeing
cbm using jin's forward four as much uh
which i feel like would be one of the
tools you're trying to use especially
against focus because he's gonna try to
hit you from this range that's so far
away you know if he tries to reach out
that forward forward clips you going to
get a counter combo right so
uh yeah it's kind of curious that we
haven't seen that on a cbm just yet but
you know you mentioned he has a lars
maybe we'll see a character switch here
uh infest is [ __ ] wrong though you
know looks very compact right he's not
really trying to do too much of the
character just using the three one a lot
in the rounds uh if i'm cbm i'm looking
especially for that three one though
right like just deduct that the one in
it and get a punish on it but gonna
switch stage here sticks to geometric
plane gonna be where we go for cbm
uh yeah he didn't really get anything
started cbm was playing really hesitant
that first game
yeah and if festus was just uh you know
basically playing keep out and um
yeah he had a couple tried a couple of
ford fours but nothing was connecting
really and he just kind of like
he just kind of like uh froze up i think
round one
let's see what happens game two now to
kick things off
oh
there you go
there we go here's something to get
things started
oh it's blocked there we're still here
very mango
stepping
yeah oh back to one yeah using these uh
yeah using these moves to look at that
range
man he wants that electric too
yeah stop this
oh okay oh magic cord
fairy barry mango going towards the wall
infested
mix up hatchet kick
moon cbm doesn't bite there
it has to try to get the walls flat down
by four tracks so far the right time
yeah that was that that was very tracked
a couple of one jabs to get things
started but backing off hook fist
there's everything a little bit more
active
yeah he is but he's really having a hard
time finding infested man he's trying
for that party just do something simpler
you know just you do do for one plus two
punch or something get the 14 frame
instead
or the easier fortune favors that but
time wind down
and at that point it's too late right
like your options are so limited
uh that it's obvious it's much more
obvious that you're gonna go for the lrk
yeah no sir
is that a range there that downforce
[Music]
infested just he looks pretty
comfortable but caribear mango
definitely
pushing a little harder
hey block
yeah very compact we might see
time running out wow
he got that low period off of the side
that's not easy to do wall carry he's
gonna be here for him
great execution
and that's
yeah that does so much damage oh my god
and it comes out so fast you're like you
don't expect it yes that's the thing
right like infested he's playing really
good back-ass keep out games uh and so
eventually cherry barry mango is getting
impact he's dashing in and then the back
one's just waiting for him
yeah surprising
oh no here we go it's the crumple
you guessed the pair yeah the first one
oh no
and this is best of three here infested
looking oh yeah put another
super strong player on his list
he's like i got me i got john ding and
i'm looking at cbm right now
cbm though backing up this corner last
chance
can we see a rage drive maybe
he's like i'm chilling bro
yeah i invested
so patient oh my god
yeah i mean it's great like what do you
do i got the standing team to keep out
exactly i got this backward if
[Music]
video when the player is about to win
they just freeze
yes
why did he keep doing it
he played that really well he just
chopped him away
invested testing care bearing mango's
patience
yes
that one does so much damage yes
oh and the wall
more combos uh-huh oh cans
you know everything falling apart for
infested right now
here we go
alive but now he might lose the set the
blue nice
wow
cbm cherry berry mango staying alive
another game and investors gonna look
back at that it's gonna be part of the
corey video next time i'm telling you
guys
he's like i got this game one i won the
whole set back back back back back back
back how did i lose how did i lose the
whole game
i was winning yeah i just stopped doing
everything that was working you know
yeah damn and it was kind of working for
a while but like cherry brain man we're
kind of new and he's like okay i know
and i'm going to push forward like if
you're going to do that i'm going to
push you towards the wall and that's the
thing about back dashing away and back
back guys back dash when there's a wall
stage i mean eventually you can't back
dash any further and basically a cherry
barrier mango is like all right i'm just
gonna like keep on poking you and he's
attacking more and at that moment he's
just it was like
at one point you're just like oh he just
poked me a bunch like how is he like
evening it up and then he was able to
take it at the end there so it adds up
especially with rage
yeah and that's the pace that's the
patient play that you expect from you
know players at this level too right i
mean they're um to be able to just do
that and not go in and try something
crazy or risky or do a health sweep
there you know um a lot of lesser
players would have succumbed i think
and also you know the the ford four and
a zen one plus two like that's something
that we hadn't really seen cbm go to uh
and i think yeah it's one of those
situations where he's playing too
respectful right he's like oh no this is
yeah this is you know topic winner's
side if i win i'm in the winner's final
i can't make any mistakes i can't take
any risks uh but then at the end he's
like nah man it's it's a video game
yeah that's a book definitely uh likes
that zen
uh one one plus two or one two right
all right let's see final game here
infinite stage
interesting choice for the infrastage
infested was the one who had the stage
choice
[Music]
and i mean it kind of makes sense right
i mean do you think [ __ ] was good with
the wall but confess his playstyle as
we've seen has been very patient very
totally throws out the high there though
and cbm this time gets the duck wall
stand two full launch combo
carry very mango so scary when he has
his momentum going
things maybe fall apart here cbm may
have built up some confidence by winning
that last game
[Music]
oh no
dead kick
all right he's been trying to find us
but he hasn't right that was the first
one he landed on first try
running three plus frames oh going back
now oh hitting running
[Music]
wow terribly mango
are we playing this game taking
advantage of his rage boost yes infested
the back ones getting i have a lead
yeah and cherry berry mango knows
oh god never lie too much health now
yeah
yeah yeah
oh
punish on a on a hook fist that's crazy
nice choice shut the duck again
cbm's gotta pull the trigger yeah he's
getting these ducks he's hiding and he
could win the rounds with them
yeah
he's not hitting anybody you get the
hard part yeah
oh okay
is so well definitely looking
yeah
i love the dash electric in that
situation yeah
yeah
there might be another one coming
yeah oh so much respect from both these
players
oh hook fist
yeah and infested doesn't want to get
hit by those
of course he really gets hit by electric
right now he's gonna lose his round
yeah yeah
yeah
he bet it on the hopkick there
set point for infested now yes
are we gonna get a final final round
here
i don't know about this one man
it's
where does life go cherry berry mango
infested puts another player
on his list
you just made the list me jumping
and cherry very mango just made the list
of players that he's taken out and now
he's a winner's final just like that
this is it
could take this whole thing he could
take this whole he's not he's he's in
great position to just if he wins the
next one right then he'll win side of
grand finals right uh so that would be
the prime position but
you know to win the whole thing he's
still got to beat the winner of our next
match which of course is jdcr
and chanel uh so either one's going to
be a great position
yeah infested guaranteed top three at
the tournament that's already a ton of
points he's in the money right he's got
the price we'll cash from this mattress
event uh he's probably going to qualify
for the regional final because of this
top three showing here so things are
looking up right things are already
looking great for infested uh but with
the whole tournament it's still
hard to save for anybody in this
tournament yeah it's true it's so
stacked and uh
yeah but
yeah infested i don't even know what he
looks like
he who knows what he looks like but i
know we do have some replays like look
at what his gameplay looked like right
uh because that last game was pretty
pretty wild and he was really back and
forth you know and the way it started
out it really felt like infested had his
number uh you know and it also kind of
felt like maybe cbm uh the parries were
going to come to play more but it really
didn't work out that way but you know in
this second game here it just it really
seemed like if this was taking control
right and that block there time winding
down any time time was winding down it
really seemed like it was against evm
like it just was not working out in his
favor uh he was always going in too late
the back test is there but this was the
round where investor hit the brakes way
too hard right he gave cbm too many
chances to come back and then the down
four beat the rage drive they're so
lucky they got it early enough and just
like that yeah it goes to final round
yeah they're fine for two after four and
also a big lead here and you know cbm's
gonna end up tying it up but regarding
this situation is so loud uh regardless
of all that right
you know this i really thought would
this happen he found that electric the
end round one final game i thought this
is it cbm's got momentum right now uh
but invested you know he stayed composed
he's like yeah whatever dude poked my
poke that's all i need was [ __ ] wrong
like i don't need big hits big launchers
although he did find something like that
uh but overall it was really just like
the down forwards and standing three
ones on the downford one strings that
were just really adding up over time
and saw keep out with the one twos there
uh man yeah just cbm you could tell like
he was he's getting shut down he was
like trying to force his way in you know
the turtle strategy of confession was
working against him he's like man i
can't get in on this guy he's got too
much wings it's dangerously i can't work
my way around it uh it's just hard to
deal with it well played to infected
moving on to the winner's final
yeah i mean that defensive plays out
definitely um i feel like cherry bare
mango didn't really know what to do i
mean he didn't have the patience um for
you know a lot of the match but
at just one point um i felt like it was
just too much too strong of uh defense
just the wall uh but yeah we're here
with the uh the bracket and of course
invested here in winners finals this is
super exciting uh this is a player that
we don't know who he looks like he's
sitting here in the winter final uh
ready to play the winner
of uh jdcr uh or chanel and uh here in
the loser's bracket we still got saint
versus bread man and uh and moyle versus
need the winner which will face cherry
berry mango crazy stack tournament and
yeah
all these matches are going to be going
to be marking matches
yeah you know when you're cherry berry
mango and you look at where you end up
in losing bracket you're like that side
of loser bracket dang it you know like
yeah oh boy definitely uh
but you know you never know what's gonna
happen so you know focus up pay
attention to how they're playing their
matchups uh but yes coming up next we
have jdcr and janelle i assume we're
going to see arma king out of jdcr here
uh also though you know he's got to kind
of guess around which character chanel
is going to bring to the table so he may
pick something based off of those
options so it could be something
different uh but you know jdcr fan
favorite out here uh chanel also a bit
of a fan favorite as well so this is two
heavy hitters that everybody knows and
only one of them can make it into this
winter final uh against infested of
course so that's gonna be cool
yeah this is gonna be a crazy match and
infested i mean whoever wins this one
they're gonna have to face infested and
that's just another opportunity for
infested to uh take his streak even
further right so uh you know he's
already beaten me junting and cherry
berry bango um yeah we'll have to see uh
who he faces um and but this one will be
a uh a best of five though right in the
winner's finals so um yes maybe we'll
see how infested fares in the uh
the longer set
um
yeah super excited about this one
yeah exactly you know and you know with
black women along the set though i feel
like you still got all the tools and
that was one of the things i heard a lot
of players criticize about the
characters like you know these newer
cases that come out they have moveless
size to match all the legacy characters
but they're all useful because they're
all built after tekken 7's already out
you know a lot of the other characters
older moves like yeah this was built in
second one way before a homing move
existed you know or uh yeah second three
waiting for holy movie existed etc so
it's a pretty interesting criticism of
the newer dlc characters uh and you know
it's not really a good way to to create
a character like that otherwise like
what do you give them strings that are
useless intentionally
uh so
it's it's pretty it's pretty much
imprisonment i really um enjoy thinking
about that so
regardless of what i'm definitely a
strong character right now and you know
um we'll see if he can win the
tournament that would be the big
question mark right now
um but coming up arma king got some
buffs you know jdr i heard him talking i
think it was just last night actually
maybe the night before and he was saying
that he thinks arma king is still
not like a top tournament character
because he doesn't have enough combo
damage that was his thought on it
and personally i feel like arm king is
the kind of character where you take a
little bit more risk sometimes although
maybe with the latest pack you don't
really have too much right because the
404 neutral 2 isn't -15 anymore right so
i think it's only -14 now uh so that
makes it a little bit safer to approach
so i feel like the balance team has done
a lot of things to help out jdcr here
with armageddon and heihachi all right
jd you can't lose this tournament now no
pressure
all right we'll see who these who these
players pick i mean that's that's a big
question right now i mean both these
players pick a lot of characters
all right and we got eliza
versus armor king
and howard estate
yeah
so this is the thing about chanel you
just
yeah he he's
you know he has the three he has the
three characters alyssa eliza um
uh and that's afina that he commonly
picks
uh he's definitely done this
intentionally
yeah this is the character i recognize
as like his tekken 7 character though
like i know he's got this athena as well
uh lisa's always been like the old
school main but in tekken 7 has
primarily been the eliza for me uh but
look at a huge 10 second and he's
already taken off seventy percent off
jcr health bar here
oh it calls out the grab attempt
yeah
so high on the wall
yeah that round two oh he's popping off
the dice round meter yeah because it
doesn't count so it's fine yeah
oh boy
pick it up
jbc right here dive not really getting
anything started back to the wall
oh try it for the wall splat but it gets
blocked
good punish
these 2d characters
yeah
oh man just kicks
backing up looking for something yeah
just trying to find the right moment
oh slowly turning things around trying
to get chanel to the wall
[Music]
and since you got that forward three mix
four four three mix up now it's so hard
to punch like or duck the high like in
the past you would always duck that high
there right there but you know now that
she's got a mid mix you don't really
want to duck 10 seconds he hit him
with the second part
the ex dive kick nice gotta chill good
five seconds what you can do just sleep
on them
roll away lay down and then roll yeah
take a nap
in the top eight i've seen him
didn't do that to knee before as well in
a very big i mean it was a good strategy
because arbitrary drive is gonna be a
guaranteed throw attempt for a comeback
so get on the floor yeah
yeah yeah
chanel with a two round lead here
against jdcr
jc are not able to do anything really
started yet okay here we go nice
sidewalk great sidewalk you got this
man chanel is intentionally oh boy that
was a big mistake
yes but he has full blood meter right
now he's making a big mistake
oh
and now he's all caught up here he still
has a bar to work with could steal it
yes
no round round that's my favorite clip
in the icf intro by the way of you
saying no round brown i love it it's one
of my favorites uh but you know one of
the things in this set specifically
that
uh chanel is doing right right from the
gecko right around one he's forcing
these duck states to frustrate jcr right
like jason came for the gravity and
chanel's like i'm ducking i'm gonna be
ducking so then later on it said he's
like i'm not ducking anymore but he
he'll duck for a little bit to make him
think he's gonna extend a duck and any
stand guards so that little mind game
defensively it's it's mixing jcr up you
can see his offense it's like it's a
little bit off like he's like oh he's
gonna stay duck in here so he went for a
minute he's like i'm stand guarding
that's not a big deal uh so jd's got to
figure that out obviously but chanel
looking really really good right now uh
and those small mistakes when jd really
added up there you know like swinging
into the ex dive kick that one situation
uh and at the very end you know i forgot
which party got caught i think just to
punish into the wall splat off axis and
chanel was just so good to confirm and
just switching up the punish uh
recognize that the wall was going to be
there for the splat so just really well
played by chanel
yeah um i'm guessing uh jcr is probably
gonna
stick with armor king imagine i mean he
does have a dragon off that he can um
bust out but uh yeah i mean no uh i
yeah i've seen him i've seen him play
dragon off not too long ago actually so
he hasn't really
completely switched over to armor king
so it's it is a possibility
i'm i'm really like and that was a no
round right he's actually a pick here it
was uh i think he'll stick with arm king
but i wouldn't be surprised if hey and i
don't even mean that just because of
like the meme about heihachi whatever
uh but yeah he sticks out with arnold
king here infinite stage is the choice
didn't like dealing with the wall
pressure from eliza uh this is i mean
that's one of the things i think people
you know undervalue about eliza just her
wall makes a potential with her down
three oh exex
or even just the uh the down forward
three which is the jumping roaming mid
wall bounce you know it's like dude that
move is so good
oh all right here multi throws incoming
he definitely did not go for early
because you know was doing that duck
game on them
yeah
oh cool sidewalk there
made the slide
all right no more walls now oh a second
time
those were running high attack that time
uh also eliza you know had very good
wall carry some of the best in the game
actually just people don't really talk
about it the beautiful coffin
they're gonna finish
i can't believe jcr did that he took a
risk there very nice you know and if she
now had chanel had stayed up in there
that could have been the round
no
a little nice block there
yeah jd
chanel
oh man i wonder if he's going for a
super confirm
[Music]
dcr definitely looking like he has way
more control in this match
it doesn't have to deal with like the
walls at all right
yeah he looks way more comfortable
because those like short range dive
kicks short range low dive from game one
we're such a pain get the pick up here
time went down has wait for rage art
not gonna kill but seven seconds yeah
it's gonna be enough time for jd to come
back in and put some kind of offense on
him chanel has one bar though so he
might see like an ex dive kick for keep
out or something to burn
i think he did the shoulder
yeah it was crazy
right jc are working on his own row
around brown
it wasn't enough yes oh shoulder the
plus frames
kcr it's blocking
oh here we go i can't try to block this
says chanel
enter that forward for neutral too
finally
are you not seeing these dives that we
saw from game one
yeah oh look at that spacing
jdcr looking in control even with the
light deficit here oh no
and yeah yeah that was trying to oh i
got a catch too girl
let's go jd wow
that's one game i didn't expect that
that was nice
uh
but yeah you know the the short range
dive kicks again from game one we
haven't seen any of those and that might
be because the infinite stage you know
right there in that situation the very
end though there was a while standing
two from chanel he's trying to find
something like that back that boom got
the punishment that was clean very very
clean yeah he's definitely way more
control in that match and i think it is
definitely a big part in having that
infinite stage where you know it's also
the comfort of being able to kind of
move without you can move back without
thinking about that right that's that's
kind of on your mind and uh just you
could just tell that that just made him
way more comfortable in that match and
he was able to get the spacing that he
wanted and he was able to do some pretty
good whip punishes there um you know uh
elicit that uh that last width from
chanel uh to uh to get a big punish and
yeah just uh just overall uh look way
more comfortable now that makes me
wonder is chanel going to you know
re-switch the stage and go somewhere
else uh to try to uh you know get those
ex wall splats again and be that threat
with the down three um yeah we'll have
to see
yeah it's interesting because i saw the
chad mention that chanel's usually the
one who fixed infinite stage so
i think in this instance he should pick
a wall fade just because the opponent
picked an infinite state you know like
i'm not going to give you what you want
just for that reason right even if it's
what i like i don't want to give you
what you want
yeah and uh looks like here uh yeah
chanel is is picking the uh wall stage
which is really interesting because he's
usually the one who's always picking
that uh infinite zero two the night
stage and uh yeah just seeing this like
he definitely wants that wall
hey
booker t
good block
wow he ducked the throat but wrong
punished
he's so patient because he's trying to
hold his position
he knows the wall is behind chanel yeah
oh where's that counter hit yeah
oh man
boom round
yeah blocks to get up for punishment
perfectly played there from jdcr
what a pickup
yeah man he converted out
yeah
he's gonna fight engagement
that was happening a real hard time
breaking duty yeah
[Applause]
oh look at this
oh okay nice low carry
that looks intense what did we get out
of the wall carry here yup i told you a
wall carries crazy
got blood meter oh but no just another
boot there
jdcr not clustered looking on another
note around round here
it's the best of three of course that'll
be pretty good
yeah this is to go to the winner's final
jd can get one more round there's the
correct punch
yes
got full blood meter now
the jdc are out of there jd is willing
he's willing to take the lows right now
that's the big difference here and
chanel is not hasn't recognized would
finally clip them all right all right
it's not gonna be the round but it's
gonna be close
sidewall situation beautiful combo
conversion
and a cancel to make sure
chanel on the board here on this last
game
jumping god
oh man oh boy why did they give her that
one
yeah
so scary oh good block there
he was so ready for that
yeah just jabbing he recognized as soon
as he went to meet her he's like he's
like he's gonna burst meter he's gonna
hit some block with nothing else i don't
care if he doesn't block i'm gonna be
ready to jab jd cr moving to winners
final gonna be going up against infested
there later of course
chanel though sent on down to that loser
bracket uh where it's gonna be ugly i
think he's gonna play either against
safe or someone else i think that's the
side of the bracket he ended up on right
here it is here's yeah now move down
that loser bracket can be playing the
winner of either saint or bread man
uh wild that was wild so jdc are
impressive come back there right was
down three round to none the first game
there with that no round brown as you
mentioned uh but brought it back with
one of his own and then the final game
closing it out looking really clean the
whole way through with that armor king
yeah yeah and uh and once again we're
back to the infested narrative we have
uh you know um he's gonna be playing
jdcr in uh winners and that's it's gonna
be a tough match but he has run through
the gauntlet we'll see if this will be
the the match where he will be sent to
losers but of course in losers we
there's so many so many strong players
right now and um
uh we have yet to have the uh the saint
breadman match uh malia versus knee uh a
very exciting one
oh yeah tons of crazy matches
uh tons of crazy matches to come up next
right uh but of course this is korea
there's a lot of players that we've all
uh i don't think growing up watching but
you know basically have uh for years now
but here is the schedule of all the
events you can see this is the last
weekend the online match events right so
this is october 9th and 10th there at
the very bottom of the left-sided screen
region 13-14 tonight is korea tomorrow
will be japan to close out our online
match event and then starting november
6th we'll be starting off the regional
finals event these are gonna be six
thousand dollar prize pool tournaments
in all these regions across the world
you guys won't want to miss it top
action from around the world as you guys
have seen throughout here of course the
points to get into the greek finals come
from dojo so if you guys have online
dojos they end october 10th hey it's
like october 8th or 9th depending on
what part of the world you're in right
now so make sure you guys are getting
those dojo points last second especially
if you're on the bubble there right
you're trying to get that topic you make
those regional finals submit your
application if you guys are a player
make sure you guys visit this website
down below you know make sure you're
part of the leaderboard make sure you
see your ranking because if you don't
then you didn't click the right button
all right so make sure you go to this
website do that that ends like today you
might have like less than an hour left
time is ticking all right you better
have done this really you've had months
at this point all right
hopefully you guys are all in there
you've got your points things are
squared away and you'll be good to go
for the regional finals
yep and uh yeah this uh this next match
i think uh we're getting genuine gaming
saint versus red men as the next match
um we have a saint who likes to pick uh
ganyu these days um i think he's gonna
probably choose gonorrhea against uh
bread man who uh he's been playing leroy
a lot but he's not afraid to uh bust out
uh fakamram um or or lydia i've seen uh
breadman when lydia first came out he uh
he's beasting with her uh we haven't
seen olivia actually this this
changed
tournament
so
through bread man
and we heard a lot about lydia being
potentially a top five character uh yeah
it's one of those characters i mean she
only came out in like june i think she's
only been around for like four months or
so uh so yeah it really hasn't been
enough time to really say where that
character ends up but we haven't seen
enough tournaments with enough top
players using this character so i'm
hoping that brad man does give us some
lydia uh or that we just do get some
lydia you know exposure in this
tournament itself right we still have me
in the tournament you know he knows how
to use every character so we may even
see one from knee later depending on
who's going against it what needs to be
done there but let's see what character
batman decides to go with here
drum roll
all right we got leroy
uh you can't go wrong with me
i feel like you just can't go wrong for
sure
yeah i would say his weakness is his
range actually he doesn't have a lot of
good like mid-range tools like it's like
down one plus two four four two two is a
good gap closer i guess
uh it's a little bit punishable though
like his back will plus two 12 frame mid
countered launcher is fantastic frame
data wise but
uh it is very short right it's very
short range and it has a lot of recovery
frames that they added i think they
added 10 recovery frames to it when they
changed it into the patch wherever i go
oh this ain't just going in
yeah and leroy's downfall one is
actually one of the best things about
him like the range on that move is crazy
like if there's a fan trying to
backstream blow that down one's gonna
find him uh which is just ridiculous and
also very low the ground to pick up the
combos too
red man here with the launch redman
combos sending saint
oh
like he was scared of a low poke right
so you probably tried a fuzzy low
prairie or low block and the rage i just
clipped them
uh so bread man with that first round
nice perry second hit there yeah perry
is definitely leroy's best tool right
yeah it makes them so scary just they're
back oh here we go
three jabs until down four two yo
yeah amazing
all right you can do it again
brad mad looking to do something rage oh
there's a stick we're talking about
visual range he does have the stick yeah
but saint is a nun
i know that that's hard to duck and
punish but to throw out a hide in that
situation
cojones
he's such a jack player right that's
basically down back one four times to do
it down four or two right yeah yeah
yeah oh man
yeah
yes
red man
at the wall down
saint doing whatever he wants
oh this foot over here bro
i do what i want everything's going to
hit
rent-free dude
crazy yeah that was
definitely for a game one situation to
have that many correct reads it's pretty
bonkers uh you know say definitely
playing fantastic right now but bread
man uh definitely lost and confused at
the moment like how the hell is
everything wrong you know it's like he
might as well be in vegas you know
gambling on slots and losing every
single time because he's that's
literally what's happening right now uh
sandy's on point every decision is the
correct one it's crazy
yeah yeah those
threes
there's definitely like that mental game
you're talking about the the downpour
threes and the you know and then the
mids uh mixing it up and uh and
definitely i felt like he he kind of he
kind of like clammed up a little bit and
like it's just like oh nothing's working
so i'm just gonna block and he just kind
of got himself to the wall and and i
just pressured him to death there so
um so yeah he's gonna have to shake it
off maybe maybe this will be what uh
prompts him to make the switch switch to
lydia
i feel like i would if i'm leroy and i'm
dealing with someone who i know it's
good he's going to mix with one of the
two options i'm just spamming perry for
every option like yeah just i'm going to
parry if the lawyer has been losing him
hit me anyway if he does the myth
yeah
uh
yeah maybe that's what he needs to see
though to go to we're in howard says
howard estate now
um
yeah st just being a bully so far
[Music]
mm-hmm one all right
fight power to stay we saw brad man on
the stage before i did pretty well with
it uh you know that sweet from leroy
does break the wall as well so the sweep
becomes a combo starter at that
situation
probably what he's thinking about
yeah
duck no duck
oh again oh okay nice sidewalk here
not a nice combo though oh
finishing the strings yeah finishes the
string yeah
foot
and you know there's no parry's coming
out from bread man here right very very
minimal i should say yeah and one of the
objects leroy has he has a ford one
which is like an attack that has a very
built in so it's like if you're scared
to just whip a parry there's the parries
at least
there's a hitbox behind it
there's a duck this time
yeah
okay scared of the third hit there
yeah try and try or go maybe get one of
those downward threes okay
take your stick out of here no canes
allowed
big name boom to the wall and the wall
then he's gonna be able to kill here
this
dude is a combo
this is beat down
hey chad you guys are all still talking
about how leroy's broken right
yeah
oh
look at that
that was so perfect from say a spacing
on that
and garner looking so strong right now
okay here we go here comes the sleeve
clap
collapsing crumples oh switching side
though
yeah stan is still a little bit too
copper right now yeah
he is slowing it down a little bit
with rage
oh
man
wow three rounds straight out here leroy
out of here out of the tournament see
you later thanks for playing uh damn
nice try for bread man but really saint
was all over all the right decisions
there uh and you know he was trying he
was doing the leroy things but they just
nothing was working and that one get up
kickbait that same thing like he dashed
in stopped out of range like you can do
get a kick yeah let it whiff boom
beautiful yeah beautiful stuff yeah
insane uh staying in the tournament
moving on uh
i forget who his opponent is gonna be
that means i think it's gonna be
chanelle right oh the matches are crazy
chanel gets both old echo fox boys crazy
yes
throwback
oh my gosh i'm coming up next down below
that you see it already royal going up
against me
winner gets cherry berry mango
chicken online challenge 2021 korea
and uh you know these uh you know you
don't see him um too much i mean he got
more known uh you know after everything
you know went crazy with the world and
and he hasn't really had the the same
chance to uh to break out to the
international audience as uh other
players have um so you know this is
gonna be a good opportunity his piece uh
it's definitely been recognized i mean
you're talking about uh uh how they did
the exhibition with chicorin uh the
other uh super godlike geese player uh
so um yeah these
these two players have met each other a
lot uh in korea there are a lot of these
um
tournaments run by uh after tv and they
do these um uh you know uh big prize
pool tournaments where uh you know
there's a lot on the line and moyle and
knee uh have met each other a lot mo
moyle has actually won a lot of those uh
tournaments so there's germans that are
going on in korea that um that i guess a
lot of people maybe in the west
haven't had a chance to see so um
definitely in korea is regarded as a
very very strong player that perhaps um
hasn't been uh able to show off his
stuff in an international audience as
much as some of these other players so
i'm very excited for uh him to
potentially i mean if there's any player
that you can show off your stuff with
it's knee if you can beat me i mean
that's you know you're on the back right
and so
you mentioned that he's won some of
these terms uh you just has he beat me
in these tournaments too like i've heard
of moyo i've like seen him play but not
much right i know he's like a killer out
here in korea right but
like this is as you mentioned a great
opportunity right uh knee into top aid
barely got in uh beat up eye musician to
get in here uh but obviously lost to
infested earlier in the bracket
and look at this i asked for it and we
got it knee with lydia
uh yes going up against the geese
boy oh boy
all right and i'm wondering what knee
has
in store
yes
this is i assume we're gonna see a lot
of political storm from lydia it's like
this long range forward yeah move uh
minus tennis blocks he's got a counter
though you know
geese's counter though yeah i don't know
but then again
doesn't really use the counter much i
don't think we've seen a music counter
at all this might be yeah well uh he'll
bring it out in those clutch moments
though right i mean yeah yeah i hope so
he has done that and the technique just
takes it erases your life bar so
we'll see we'll see if neal be careful
anyone's gonna be careful it's me
yeah
yeah establishing their offensive
pattern
yeah
think about this
and me definitely
finally down four counter hit yeah
that really seems to be one of like the
uh the trademarks of them man that space
it was so good
better oh my god
oh
my god your spring cake
fight
let's just visually look crazy
it's two fists like kicking both his
feet
yeah so wise honey tweeting out that he
thinks lydia is
the uh best female character in the game
that namco's ever created
oh wow okay yeah i've heard i've heard
such as black right oh yes demo man gets
blocked
big punish here from malio
nice
juicy combo here
two bars meter
oh
needle way behind small pictures
oh okay demo man let's mix up thanks
wow of course do it again do it again
yes he had that rage boost there's so
much damage they're canceling it down
for excuse me a bar oh i just tried for
a forward four there
did you see how small that size was for
the air fireball there that was so clean
yeah yeah it's like that was enough
i'm coming in though
yeah
i can't do that with the eddy
oh get out of here girl
are you kidding oh my god that was so
awesome no
cliff that combo that was ridiculous oh
my god oh like no way he's gonna like
get that wall combo and finish
he'd use the weird points
he got the whole round with it
yeah
oh here we go
there's a big combo with the mix-up
following
oh the
oh no oh okay block and knee with rage
very dangerous right now
and he would wait but yeah well's got
almost two bars
yeah devil man
going for the rage
okay
[Music]
here we go
combo yeah and this is
this is geese with meter
and the wall combo in this small stage
how much damage was that got another bar
too
yes
yeah lydia is not like the comeback
she's not like the pokemon or you
already feeling around with your life
yeah or like even like a martic
situation
he's got to earn it a little bit
oh okay where did you feel like this
with the rage though is the hopkins
again yeah
he thought he's gonna do it again
beautiful crazy yeah
you know at that moment like that's
that's scary because he was in that
moment before right he was you know uh
he got
he had me and he was in rage and he was
uh it was in a position okay position
where he could do that demoman again
remember he did the devilman two times
in a row and basically he this time he
did it once and you know demo man with
like uh with rage boost does so much
damage right and then after you know he
got up the second after that i think he
was just like oh
i guess he could do it again that's what
he did last time and yeah he got hit by
uh he got hit by the blue stuff
almost made that comeback yeah or yeah
yeah yeah and so that was ridiculous and
so the crazy thing about that situation
was he he took the first one right and
in that situation you got a big likely
times winding down you don't have to get
up off the ground that's one of the
things about tekken right you don't have
to get up off the ground you can just
take inside or whatever lydia can like
hit you around and flip you over and you
can kind of get out of the situation a
little bit that way uh but he got up
like and i was like why did he get up
and as soon as he did
there came the rage driver he ducked for
it right
yeah yeah that's a risky situation he
put himself into
uh but honestly it paid out like
thankfully he had built up enough meter
you're going to a final round with geese
when you've got two bars that's a great
situation for you
yeah
yeah and uh
and yeah this is uh this is a quick uh
best of three match so um yeah moe will
just have to win one more to take out me
but uh yeah
if you go back to the beginning of the
screen where we're talking about like
akuma and tekken you know and uh the
holders versus the zoners and all this
stuff right like like that's something
you've not used with a tekken player
like what do you mean a wake up soup oh
yeah you know that i can't get through
it's got invincibility what
yeah yeah break so it's definitely a
rule breaker but it's so hyped what
happens because you never get a seat
it's so rare especially final round
final hit
yes
and that knee
pushing forward
sticking with the video
[Music]
oh wow there's the hot board for
yeah
yeah definitely
definitely was more offensive there
still
pushing forward
yeah
pick an owner hit whoa did you see that
run
that was weird he's stopping he could've
got a tackle out of it
[Music]
okay oh yes now i'm back three oh tried
up four four again yeah and he's been
going upward for
quite a bit
yeah it's because it's the mix right for
like that damn actually low
beautiful and already two rounds
up neat this is so fast yeah wow
yeah and moy has like no meter either
yeah he like haven't really done
anything look at this
board four dude
that was a little fun that was so clean
yeah you know everyone talks about the
storm
and yeah
yeah he's like just stay closer and just
kick him in the face bro yeah just the
basics oh big counter hit okay moyo
coming back here
saying i don't want to get around brown
here
oh
not over here this is a little scary for
me though not to be
yeah yeah
[Music]
oh he's got him at the wall
oh you'll get up here boyle has two bars
get back up here oh my god
and the mix up jump in oh
on the grab yes
and just like that lydia pulling through
for me uh you know committed to the
character choice there uh and that was
such an interesting choice for the throw
attempt right like i mean yeah yeah
tekken 7 throws you know we've talked
about plenty it's not it's not that
difficult to break especially the
highest levels of the game especially
when you have a character like geese
where it's not really a mix-up it's like
just a regular grab or one plus two uh
you know for a tekken veteran like me
i'm gonna guess he's gonna break that
most often right unless you're trying to
use it to switch positions on a throw
escape or something but in that
situation so odd you know it's such a
risky choice
uh but regardless me gets the game uh
ties it up final game incoming lose a
bracket here so knee facing elimination
still
uh both of them are facing lupita nation
obviously but obviously i know a lot of
you people in chat are probably big me
fans right so everyone wants to see me
do well in tournaments and uh right now
it's looking a little scary to be honest
it's looking very scary
yeah um he did uh he did come back a bit
he got his momentum back and definitely
uh knee played his game um you know
where you were talking about no
political storms or anything like it
just just
you know hop kick at the right moment
you know just bait um beta whiff and
hopkin he got a ton of damage uh that
that game so we'll have to see um you
know if he sticks that he's definitely
more uh active and and pushing forward
but um but yeah this is the this is the
final game
all right precipice of fate
geese and lydia of course
what a dramatic i'm really shocking
super dramatic right depressive
who's getting thrown off this cliff you
know yeah
a president that's what it should be
it should be like a fatality pit
fatality stage so you know get thrown
off into the volcano or something
yeah yeah
all
right this is crazy we're getting into
it final game here with loyal versus me
hey
yeah and
you're active now
realizing that knee has adapted
oh okay here's the question demo man
yeah he's been establishing you know
this down by three hopkins mix-up game
uh and he's having really good success
both obviously pretty punishable so you
got to be right
on your wreath
yeah just
it's a bunch of jabs right now stepping
nothing crazy but knee with rage
oh get down for it
there's the rage and this
this is going to get wall damage it's a
problem
oh it doesn't finish it out quite yet
let's jump in jump come here using the
meter oh ho
he delayed that dude
yeah he delayed that low key just a
little bit that me wouldn't go for like
a quick little parry beautiful time
again and boy with the first round there
uh but he's got to be careful man every
time that knees got rage you know boy
he's ducking for those down back threes
and he's being called these rape drives
just getting
[Music]
oh good duck
the knee with rage air fireball
oh just this is just right
i'm so careful
said point your knee facing elimination
right now
he needs to make a three round come back
get the hockey double dash in the face
block's good
yeah
oh oh oh boyle got a bar now got a bar
now
yeah oh man
you could be dead this he's got rage too
with the bounce
he needs a miracle there's a raider
ggs thanks for playing me goes home at
seventh place boyle advancing into the
top five of the tekken online challenge
2021 for korea wow wow wow
yeah that was uh
that was really good stuff from oil that
was that was crazy yeah you were talking
about the the the mid parry you know the
the one that doesn't although we don't
really see it how he doesn't really use
it right but you know yeah um
you know that's if you have a strong
move and uh you know you can you can
also save it too right and sometimes at
this this high level you you got to do
that and yeah that's how he took that
game and uh yeah taking someone out like
me uh great stuff from oil but of course
is regarded as one of the uh the top
players of korea in uh you know this
this year and last year um and uh yeah
he's just proved that uh he's definitely
one of the best players coming out of
korea and he will be playing cherry
berry mango uh another super strong
player oh we got the replay here yeah is
that uh down back three two
yeah yeah but then
oh yeah this is a oh no this isn't the
accomplishment yeah yeah this is still
the first game right this was like the
crazy uh comeback and this
right here yeah jumping that wall down
here yes for him yeah oh yeah
the situation
yeah yeah right here the raging door
yeah
oh man he was pressing so hard there i
mean he might have died just from chip
to be honest and the counters were
coming out just when he needed to you
know he doesn't really use it much i
mentioned probably saving it uh and
against someone like me such a smart
strategy right because so many people
are like just expecting it from geese
but you're like oh this guy doesn't use
it i can do whatever i want to him and
he's like no just i just saved it now i
have it yeah
and you're burning the meter yeah that
off time there was so good
yeah yeah
definitely had a strategy to finish that
off
there's some jabs there and and mueller
definitely seem more confident in this
game oh here we are
this is the uh the wall-bound
rage
um
yeah just all around
great stuff from moyle uh that's a no
round brown against me you know exactly
and then yeah in the last game yeah no
round brown uh
it was it wasn't like a seam rolling but
it was a no round brown and moyle uh
yeah just
uh
yes super strong player
but
we uh
we have to show off some uh some
some shirts right actually i didn't get
to show off yes if you have a stick
shirt i have yeah don't ask me okay but
we got
a bunch of goodies yeah we got some
shirts here yeah
yeah paul phoenix king and martial law
uh grab them now while you can guys
because these will sell out uh cute ass
tekken shirts as well nina anna leroy
sugar king arm king and julie chang
available 10 0 10 dasho dot gg slash
merch or you guys can just scan that qr
code and get to the website that way we
also got this kudi mitsu limited edition
pre-order now right so pre-order now get
in there so you get your size etc uh
because i really like this purple and
pink color scheme but it's probably
gonna disappear right so not a lot of
opportunities to get those so head on
over to 10-0 gg slash merch to grab it
all right and don't forget guys we also
got some socials for you yeah you can
take it
all right yep we got bne esports on
twitter and got youtube uh tekken on
twitter we got twitch we got tekken
everywhere twitch and facebook uh don't
forget to follow these uh networks so
that you can get the latest news on the
latest tekken tournaments
so by the way
take a break okay all right well you can
tell me about the shirts first if you
want
oh and i just want to say that i have
the paul good afternoon shirt and yeah i
actually had a black but
uh it's uh it's the black one yeah so i
i wanted to wear that one but i couldn't
find it today but uh so i just kind of
wore this actually i i i think i had a
lot of cat hair on it my watch didn't
want me to wear that one
all right guys
sorry and when we come back top four
don't go anywhere top five we'll be back
after this
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
flying
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and welcome back to the tekken online
channel 2021 for korea i'm rip here with
corey gaming gerald it's been a fun
tournament so far we are working our way
into the top five right now lots of
great matches all around hybrid enjoying
it gerald
oh it's it's been crazy i mean if you
guys uh if you guys are just tuning in
there's been some crazy matches um even
starting from uh before top eight uh
from the very beginning every match has
been a crazy marquee match-up and uh the
last one we just we saw was a moyle
taking out me in this top eight you know
this just comes crazy back this
tournament is yeah and the guy who put
me in the loser's bracket is a player
that no one really knows too much about
uh he got on he got a rock sponsorship
um
it must have been very recent and uh
he's made it all the way to winner's
final he hasn't no one's able to to uh
to stop him yet and uh he had to beat me
junting cherry berry mango to get up
there and he's going to be playing jdcr
so um very interested in watching this
player play very patient play style you
can tell he's uh he's a type of player
to never give anything away and uh we
saw that when he had the match against
cherryberry mango so um very interesting
but jdcr of course uh no stranger to
playing against any kind of playstyle
defensive offensive whatever you can
deal with at all so uh
yeah we'll have to see uh what we have
for that match and then there's chanel
versus st i mean that's a classic uh
that's been
a match that we've had for forever um
and uh cherry bear mango versus moyle
exactly lots of great matches guys and
of course technolon challenge is brought
to you by asheville the official headset
and mix amp of the tekken online
challenge 2021 huge house astro for
supporting all things checking out here
uh and as you just mentioned daryl we
got a lot of crazy good matches coming
our way uh the winner finally we're
going to get to later is going to be
very interesting right we know in fact
he got the [ __ ] rom he's also has the
negan potentially jcr rocking that armor
king but you know he's also got a
pokemon result we might get a [ __ ]
raw mirror match in the winter final
like that would be beautifully
disgusting you know what i mean
at the time of the loser bracket we've
got chanel going up against saint that's
a classic plus we got cherry berry mango
going up against moyo who just
eliminated me from the tournament right
so lots of really good matches still to
come here as we are working our way
through this top eight uh just the top
five right now but uh the math coming up
next you see it down below chanel versus
saint right so obviously saying probably
going to be rocking again ryu uh and the
way he beat brad man just a second
though with just the correct leads on
all his downforce threes and downpour
two mix-ups was just phenomenal so if he
keeps playing that way and you know he's
got the right wing all his opponents
this is a very scary saying who sent
same to the loser bracket even i'm gonna
take a look and find out that's oh yeah
wow cause he's playing really good right
now
uh looks like it was acting john no no
no i wasn't
who sent santa to lose a bracket
i think he beat junting to get into top
eight
uh exactly he lost to i musician so the
player that beat sane is out of the
tournament so all these guy in top eight
they haven't beat st today you know only
i musician did and he's not in here
anymore so this is gonna be very
interesting to play out because a lot of
times not a lot of times but sometimes
when you're in these top eights that's
what happens you know the one guy who
could stop this guy is out of the
tournament uh let's see if it plays out
that way saint versus chanel incoming
chanel probably rocking the
eliza yes it is yep
all right genuine gaming saint versus
uh rox gaming's uh eliza uh chanel
eliza eliza is crazy from him and it's
so good the the low dive kicks
uh and just the pressure he creates out
of that right uh but you saw jdcr
adapted to it i did really good on that
uh infinite stage against her so we'll
see how things down here obviously
staying jdcr gives you big time training
partners partners on echo box teammates
i should say oh oh man the jump back
dive
counter hit dive kick yeah
duck wow he actually does it but he
didn't pull the butt push the button
again
yeah both just kind of
shocking for position right now
oh here we go saints coming in
ah doesn't get the punishment there
[Music]
oh
i thought if you could get that forward
to after the dp yeah power crush through
that's a good choice
that's a great choice if you have a
quick solid power crush against a
character like eliza is doing dive kicks
all day
uh yeah it's not a mattress you know you
can only lose to throws and lows and
she's coming down airborne just gonna
armor through it
[Music]
finish with the string this time full
bar
full bar let's see if we can make
something happen with it solid lead here
around yeah use the position with the
wall there too
saint with a big life deficit though
going in down forward to threes using
that deceptive range
oh burns a bar
keeps the pressure up no saint doesn't
fight
oh okay blocks it this time
chanel just
yeah
staying back
saint huge life deficit nine seconds at
the clock he has to do something
oh he's gonna sleep already it's too
early to sleep oh he's gonna do it again
oh
that hit's grounded
but not like in the combo's animation
yeah if he had hit a button
yeah
he slept really early there i thought it
wasn't going to work
second
here's the down four too
all right this time it's safe that comes
down to early oh man okay that's the
best punch there
but full meter for chanel not even gonna
matter that round is all same four
fight
this is best of three still first game
chanel with full bar and the knockdown
situation oh
oh let's get the follow up
saint harassing all day
yes
saint with rage now
he does have a round b he might be yeah
he can afford to do something kind of
crazy but plus frames and yeah this goes
low chanel takes it takes that round
ties it up
final round
nearly full bar so personnel is a great
situation what an option get out of here
hell i have that scouted
that four one percent has a low pair
from chanel here though yeah answering
back five foot combo to the wall
dive kick pressure here no sir
hit the ex oh
keeps about the wall
sane
gotta get the wall flat okay yeah this
is not gonna kill off
yeah oh good block
that wasn't in dxdp i don't know what he
did then
he spent bar on something but it wasn't
the right choice ex dp there should have
worked i'm pretty sure
uh somebody can confirm the frame rate
on that later i think that was down
forward three into downpour one from
saying
uh but i don't know yeah it could have
been an accidental input maybe he wanted
the dp got ex fireball instead yeah uh
regardless though uh not the right
choice same get in that first game
damn
that was good
saints on a tear uh it's
with kanru of all characters right i
mean we we're in a tournament here with
you know the [ __ ] rums and the lydia
that came out and the geeses and st just
you know here with
uh the lone gone here just uh making it
work and uh you know he's gone
yeah yeah and uh you know i mean there
are there aren't a million countries
either i mean they're
you know there could even be some
character familiar unfamiliarity uh you
know the advantages of playing a
character like that so
um
but uh but yeah i mean he's been making
it work
yeah the thing about generally though
like the character hasn't really changed
a whole lot like he's got some new
stance options but the core ganry stuff
is still the core stuff and we do get a
character swap from chanel here going to
the zafina pick here
uh this one should be interesting i mean
i don't feel like eliza was necessarily
a bad matchup but i think saints showed
that he's very prepared for it right
uh so let's see how chanel's zafina is
ready to go right he's got to switch
gears real fast here
uh yeah down here
one of the seconds already
wall flat to wall splat though
just the pixel here are you gonna say
duncan i got this
oh
this choice is looking much better
chanel yeah just everything working for
chanel
and he's gonna have to
adapt here
push his way out just a little hug
switch his sides
that was very lucky
all right good round start from saint
here
pretty good 50 here
harassing away
maybe turning things around here putting
himself on the board in the second game
i feel like this is like tournament
state too when saint is coming from
behind like he's just like stepping down
like nah it's not over like it doesn't
matter if you have too long he'll find a
way it is terrifying
yeah
okay here we go oh spring kick get some
breeding room chanel oh gosh
this ain't looking really comfortable
right now
ah the squid
squid game
oh no
yeah saint just slowing it down with a
slight life lead here i'm running out
though
punish that
for once oh boy oh scary
chanel definitely bell's got real
message mode
yeah
and 10 seconds you know it's got to make
something happen
saint here just
staying back he's driving scary
oh
and this
he's gonna take the game for chanel
tying it up 1-1
wow yeah that was that was tense that
was tense i mean i was saying the race
drive is so scary here in that situation
right and so he forced the situation
there's not enough time he's got to make
one choice and it seems like all right
well it's probably a rage so i better
stand guard and then yeah slow low got
your feet yeah uh yeah
yeah
yeah that was that's
crazy choice
yeah that was very that was very
intentional that was like yeah i know
you you think i'm you know you know we
all were thinking waiting for that and
uh
yeah chanel
just yeah question out there
yeah we're to go down tomorrow with the
final game
and yeah
it's a good choice which character
series it was looking really good for my
first obviously but same you know as i
mentioned he's the kind of player that
doesn't give up after being down two
rounds and he's made the adjustments
already uh so going to the next game i
feel like it's saying shouldn't switch
characters i feel like they should be
harmonizing
yeah you know he saw what the subpoena
has to offer uh it's obviously gonna
have a little bit extra in game two but
at the same time his gamryu he
understands what he needs to do with it
i think uh the the crazy thing for me in
this masterpiece it's still that down
for three usage right because it seems
like he kind of goes rounds where he
turns it off and he turns it back on
again so
yeah i'm really curious because even if
he has low pair he's like all right you
gotta low pay well i better do it again
you know
like he just doesn't he doesn't stop
he's like don't worry it's still part of
my game plan it's not going anywhere
yeah yeah
i mean that that's that's part of the
mind games too though right i mean you
know to to stop doing the thing that's
that was working because they counted it
once like you know that's the obvious
thing to do right so um yeah you got to
mix it up and you know that explains the
hell sweeps that people do uh even after
they get blocked and punished and they
do it again immediately right
all right we're going into the final
game here
chanel versus saint
hey
that one plus two from sabina so good
too
oh broadway time hey
try for that that was such a good time
that was wonderful
and he waited for the backstreet though
to come back before he swung too
yeah otherwise it would have worked nice
and nice
i believe 11.
yeah very fast moving or maybe 10 yeah
oh damn the downforce
yeah this is definitely that everything
is working saint gandu that we've seen
before
tied up in rounds though
damn her back that gets out of the
downforce three down four three
yeah oh look at this just like that see
that yeah
and that's exactly what he's winning he
was setting him up for that he did it
three times
around that was so good yeah that was
like i know you didn't even get out of
here
just like that point now fight
[Music]
oh again the harassment yeah chanel got
to be
smart
interesting
look out
oh i got i got lows too
mm-hmm
damn he ducked after the downfall too
punish that oh
no
he's still facing down for that no
punishes they're looking for the jabs
coming after nothing coming after
oh my yeah there they came in a second
it still caught them
you know with rage still dangerous oh
just
run up back to what yeah
yeah just yeah that brought it back i
mean that's
right there at that moment is this the
predictable thing would be to just like
okay time to climb up and be
conservative right and i think saint
just knew like i'm gonna go in right now
and uh end it right here oh yeah you
know before you know i don't want this
to extend any further and he was able to
uh uh just end it right there and
uh yeah just uh uh taking out chanel
janelle's out of the tournament
yes you know that's me
that's crazy
and yeah garnier is saint making it this
far
yeah this is exactly staying into the
top four now this is wild the echo fox
boys i know they're not egg fox boys
anymore right but you know genuine
gaming same thing i lose record they're
both in the top four here in the second
seven tournament in 2021 like that's
that's so cool uh yeah we still have
cherry berry mango coming up against
moyle in just a second uh that one
probably we finally see jin against
geese howard and if if i'm not mistaken
i think that that match was pretty
pretty decent it's not terrible right
because uh he's got the perry to work
with as well uh definitely not a bad
place to be but sank with the gandhi is
still so impressive here cracking into
that top four and man i really love that
one round where it was the down forward
threes and you see
saint doing two down for threes in a row
first one hits next one chanel back
dashes right you see chanel back at duck
look for whip and punch and then he's
like all right three of them and then
next one down for three you're gonna
back that dash of boom down forward yeah
separate fan
yeah
that was uh that was some good condition
and recognizing the situation
yeah
um
yeah so um we're doing
we're down to uh you know winners final
losers quarter final here um i guess the
next match is going to be cherry berry
mango and uh and moyle uh like you said
uh probably jin but we i have seen him
play lars recently he does want to try
to get that image of being only a gym
player um
kind of maybe tone down a little bit
because people have been kind of uh kind
of saying he's uh i i i don't know maybe
character loyalty these days in 2021
maybe that's not like a boomer thing to
do
uh yeah i i don't know
yeah
yeah but i mean he's getting this
win just when you don't i don't care
like whether you win one character or
ten character just win that's what
people care about i don't care whether
one or two characters oh wow you you
only get one huh but he wins guys you
know like nobody says that
yeah just win well i mean you know uh
it's also maybe maybe the meta is uh you
know we got over 50 characters in in
tekken 7 now right so maybe the meta
calls for um you know having having
other characters uh you don't want to be
uh you know stuck to one character in
some of these situations we've seen
i think you know most players have like
a good uh at least two characters known
for like a pocket um
but uh yeah character loyalty like i
guess like
you know cherry berry bango is one of
the last few remaining players that is
very character loyal
but uh yeah we'll definitely we'll see
they're coming up right now
yeah all right we got the expected
characters for both these players
afrofreaks uh
cherry berry mango playing chin versus
uh africa fix moyo
team kill
man you know i've seen that af there all
night i didn't realize it was africa
freaks even though i've seen africa
freaking on the bracket the entire time
i just see all my
you know
uh but here we go cbm moyo jin and geese
howard hammerhead stage game one
all right all right
oh with the final fantasy stage
this might be amusing round
it might be but you know probably not if
you're losing it it depends
great spacing dabs there
yeah
i feel like geese howard is one of these
characters where if you have a character
that can pair his follow-ups uh the
prairie can become really effective
against them
yeah we'll see if cbm
uh does that how are you posting match
from general oh man he loves that cat
oh boy
yeah get off me twice
okay
slight lead here
poking away so far no no big damage yet
yeah but these pokes are adding up right
he's got over half life
yeah oh tried and electric there that
forward four keeping him out
pushing into the wall
and that's what that round was
culminating to basically uh round two
yeah
caught moyal coming in with the hook
fist
finish the round and that's one of my
favorite things about cbm's gin right
like he loves that electric yeah and he
loves landing it couch i love it yeah oh
yeah yeah
there it is
yeah we'll carry here
wow look at this round it's just
down back forward just so fast
two rounds up carry barry mango
[Music]
uh
you know have a slow start come back
later
yeah we've definitely seen that playing
out
molly
it wasn't even the duck it was this
dance transition the one he goes
backwards
[Music]
[Music]
literally jabbing him down
yeah oh the counter hit
pour and
cherry very mango tying it up in life
still a big lead so you don't have to do
anything crazy
oh my god oh
man
how many got this is that for this game
wait wait it's not done yet it's not
done yet
yeah
he's looking at sidestep you know
oh it's never over until it's over yeah
yo this is cpm's battle of stage for
comebacks bro yeah this is oh
and 2d characters let me tell you oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah the stage
music it brings back the other memory
oh the down
is the uh the parry
good chunk of damage and the wall
position
[Music]
another big lead for cbm
this time
not a full bar yet but it's gonna build
up there oh man he's gonna have the full
meter before he enters around nice
little parry yeah
there you go
but yeah i mean boyle so dangerous at
any moment he has a bar now
oh gosh oh
damn corner again
it should be good that was
that was nice
that hell sleep was nice he just like
kind of got up and he's just like yeah
i'm gonna help sleep now like you're not
gonna expect this just gotta run up
he'll sweep and yeah that was i was the
round in that game so
good stuff
yeah cbm uh definitely doesn't use that
hell sweep a lot right so it's a little
bit less predictable when he does it
however i also feel like he's only using
it and around situation where it's gonna
kill he needs to come back you know like
i feel like that's yeah the desperation
gin tactic of choice you know it's like
i'm behind i need something
it's gonna be a hell sweep you know like
that's the one they always seem to go to
um but so far it's working out right and
man is so scary anytime he's alive and
he's got meter to work with yeah you
have to be scared you know if you're
back to the wall especially scared uh
and even with geese now his wall carry
is so good that if the wall's not near
you should still be scared so if you
can't even blame him for losing that
round but moyle he's prepared to come
back in so many different ways uh that
you got to be as cautious as can be
basically but
uh so far so good cbm holding on
got the first game needs to get one more
to stay in the tournament move on to top
four
uh
trying to get two to get on there but
it's uh it looks pretty good for cbm
right now
yeah
yeah he's he's looking
pretty comfortable but i mean
we've seen moyle you know just
game two just uh just really turn it on
so uh this could be a very different
uh
game that we're going into but um
yeah we'll see round one
fight all right here we go abandoned
temple gonna be the stage
[Music]
oh and we saw how many of those we
landed
in that first game yeah good punish up
close
looking pretty loose right now yeah
exactly
got to be doing yourself to do those
[Music]
oh man
yeah kill though it doesn't matter down
three closes out but yeah the timing was
perfect he went up he pauses like
now you can hit a button boom electric
yeah that was beautiful
double back down
what is the success rate on these
electrics
uh
high very very high yeah very very high
oh okay back to one to
take that round already two rounds
cherry berry mango
this is boiled he just he just
eliminated me
and cherry berry mango here right
looking to know around he didn't have an
electron
yeah oh he got the step though
perfect combos always
yeah
so optimal
[Music]
is that a life deficit but he's
not at a round deficit he has two rounds
up
yeah and this is not enough of a life
deficit now he's got rage as well he can
definitely come back with one big
counterhead
one countered electric or one forward
four count rate
yeah but now he's got very little to
work with yeah
yeah while playing it compact
making sure that he gets that round
a lot of just simple jabs
oh yes again
yeah
what were you talking about high success
rate uh electrics
yes yeah i don't know what cbm stands
for it's probably cherry mango but it's
like some high cbs cram you know boom
the bounce
look at this
and that he's out of here
you win
cherry berry
mango
very nice very nicely done cbm moving
into the top four here uh that is pretty
impressive dude you know he looked a
little shaky when we saw him earlier on
the winning side of the bracket but
right there looking fantastic and uh top
four finish here that's fantastic boy
you know he just i don't know what it
was he just kept on getting hit by
electrics like i think that was really
the story that entire set uh if somehow
he didn't get hit by 10 electrics he
probably would have won but when you get
hit by 10 elections in trouble
yeah
yeah
oh yeah exactly like it's just all the
electrics are landing and this was the
best thing moyle got started right he
got to a side there and that's where a
lot of his successes come actually
looking back at his matches he gets a
clutch side step into like the full
combo but
these electrics all adding up full
damage there cherry berry mango 2-0 over
the man who just took out knee so well
played uh but cbm into the top four here
impressive stuff congrats yeah
yeah
yeah just uh you know cbm is uh you know
he's been known for his ford fours uh a
lot as well too right but we didn't see
too much of that in that last game i
mean he got a couple counter hits here
and there it was uh that was definitely
like a an electric gin
that we saw 100 yeah it's always hype
yeah yeah that's my favorite kind of you
know like the fourth oh yeah that's kind
of what
but yeah
beautiful right that's what we want to
see
uh cbm
uh looking really good here i'm really
excited to see what comes up next for
them
yeah
and speaking of next we got the regional
finals events coming up next uh right
after the japan event that's coming up
tomorrow so if you guys are enjoying
this korea action tomorrow is in japan
we already know there's gonna be a ton
of big players they'll be entering this
tournament it's gonna be amazing so make
sure you guys tune in for japan tomorrow
night out here same channel make sure
you guys are followed if you guys
haven't done so already but then all the
regional final events start right so
coming up next month we got south africa
to kick it off november 6th and you see
it there all the way through to january
9th to wrap it up with north america in
2022 and of course you guys don't have
points ready your time is running out
the dojos end october 10th which is like
a day away or something right so you're
running on time submit your application
now and make sure you guys also go to
the website register your account right
make sure you guys are all clicked in
there so you have the right stuff set so
you see your points show up on the
leaderboard if you look at the
leaderboard like yo dude i'm supposed to
have some points it's not there that's
what you need to do all right and you
literally
are probably too late because it's
october 9th right now and submissions in
october
we told you enough times all right i'm
sorry at this point i'm sorry for you uh
you're bad not mine bracket time top
four here we go infested jdc are gonna
be our winners final loser semis we got
genuine gaming saint versus afrika
freaks cherry berry mango
that's a wild top for now i think a lot
of people would have guessed
when you saw the brown initially
yeah there are definitely some upsets in
this tournament and you know we have an
unexpected player and rox dragons
invested in the uh the winners uh finals
um up against jdcr uh which will be the
next set oh i'm super excited about that
match and uh genuine gaming saint versus
africa freaks uh cherry berry mango who
we just saw just electric
uh the crap out of moyo in that last
game uh
yeah
yeah
yeah
beautiful yeah you know i think he just
didn't want to be known as the forward
four guy and he's like you know i i got
to be the maybe that's what it looks
like he didn't want to be the guy
yeah
it was just the forward four guy don't
be the fourth four guy be the gin guy
that's fine you know
uh but yeah very very well played by him
and obviously you know the timing there
right he definitely loyal timing uh that
the one instance that made in that match
where he just did right for like half a
second like are you ready yet here it
comes boom electric
uh that was wonderful right but coming
up we've got the winner's final right
infested versus jdcr this matchup going
to be first of three games of course
we've seen the focus infested you know
very compact gameplay of [ __ ] rom he's
not like throwing out a bunch of stuff
at you just what he needs guess which
punches he finds uh just very solid
gameplay uh jdcr you already know it's
kind of the same right uh except he's
gonna be doing with arma king probably
um i assume we're gonna see the arm king
for the rest of this tournament from
jdcr uh unless things really fall apart
for him uh in the sense that like you
know his first three army king got
smoked 6-0 rounds or something maybe
it's time to switch but i feel like even
in that situation he's sticking out his
armor kick so stop your heiachi chance
chad i know you want to
see it but you know he's not interested
all right uh he's been down that road
many times he's been down that road
he knows exactly where it ends you know
but uh yeah definitely i think we can
see the arm king and arm king is very
good right now um his arm looking at me
and the character so i'm still thinking
about that one trade he had with chanel
earlier you know like he had he had less
he had more health i think should not
nothing we just throw out the shoulder
he's like this would be a bad situation
i don't want to guess shoulder trade and
he's gonna win because it's uh the life
yeah
uh that was barely it seems like he's
putting a lot of time yeah
yeah it was very surprising too just
such a big explosion of damage on the
screen
that is a
surprise for everybody especially the
moments where like uh
it's one of those moments where you see
like both players and just all their
life is gone in the life bars and you're
like wait wait who's the one who like
who made it out yeah and
you thought you knew but you didn't
actually know
yeah
all right we're getting into all right
next match this is
yeah this is going to be uh
rocks infested playing fakumram against
uh it's jdcr's armor king as predicted
uh this is a match we're going to have
in the winners final this is going to be
a
best of five match the first of three
i'm gonna have a little bit of a long
set here
top three guaranteed both players
already but who is going to be moving on
to the grand finals
will be [ __ ] wrong we'll be arma king
infested trying to make a name for
himself already taking out a ton of
killers in the tournament took out me
took out john ding
oh my goodness look at the space from
jcr though yeah
hey hey
more than half off what's the mix up
shins
wow good block oh nice block on that low
and then to punish yeah
oh
oh
unblockable tech catch again too okay
yes
fight we've seen jbc do that a couple
times spear party
damn you trying to get a duck again
yeah
oh okay and the punishment yeah
that's not that much damage i think he's
willing to take those yeah
chopping away low infested oh ducking
there just
yeah you know waiting this is what
chanel did to jar first right like that
extended duck yeah yeah you do something
remember i'm a ducker and then knocked
up later right yeah
yeah look at the investment look at the
patience from both of you yeah yeah yeah
yeah and this was kind of expected you
know just oh wow
that's one of the way i'll describe the
players before we started here
[Applause]
oh it's rage damage boost as well
oh no
oh the combo damage okay
oh counter and get up
dunk them
stunner
and life are still very close here
got him yeah step on it
invest is still here
okay it's possible oh
this skates here just stops them out of
his uh of the startup frames fight
there's the lows now no more spears yeah
yep
trying the bit off he doesn't get ducked
again but jd
nice call out here gonna get some good
positioning
oh okay blocks the low again on point
with those punishers invested
a little slippery left ties it up the
ground
in the final round of the first game
great adaptation by investing here so
far you know jd really didn't control it
first but that's just brought it all the
way back
and now you can see he's much more
comfortable in his offense
good block
yeah he's been blocking those
oh
look at the pressure
he
are you kidding me but he dropped the
combo
yes and jdcr oh oh my god he's [ __ ]
wrong still got a little bit left it's
so dangerous
he wanted the calendar for the win
man the cajones on this man all right
yeah if jj don't like a down forward one
in that situation that could have been
the whole game for infested but instead
uh jd with a low kick that time
uh and it works out get some game uh but
that first game could have gone either
way right that was down to the wire
uh and a big big call out there from
infested it wasn't necessarily a bad
idea either i think you know
specifically against jdcr uh pretty good
call out actually but doesn't work out
yeah if you're that down in that
situation uh yeah you might might as
well go for it uh here and there but
yeah i mean i think um this is a long uh
set right so um i mean the the first
round or the first match here is going
to look different from the ones later on
of course we've been doing best of
threes uh and uh we're gonna see this uh
this
play unfold i think uh as as the games
go on and um yeah i feel like infested
is one of those players where um
you know with his he's a rock sponsored
player right and the his teammates are
chanel and knee who have this very very
patient playstyle that um i think works
really well uh and he
really tests the patience of his
opponents but i feel like jdcr is
somebody who
can definitely deal with that
yeah the thing about having a really
patient play style in this game though
is that you have to be very strong
defensively
because there's a lot of strong
offensive options game that can really
screw you up if you're trying to play
super defensive in fact we saw that
working against infested earlier in his
cbm match right when he tried to be
super defensive to close out when he was
about to win
uh so not easy to do at all especially
not at this level
of competition where their offensive
strategy is going to be so effective
against you too
uh so let's see what happens to game two
you're on super stage and look at the
spacing for the while standing three
there that was nuts
that's beautiful oh
i can't believe he did that
yeah yeah that was that was so clean
oh wait wait
break the crap
yeah good boy
box it again he keeps on blocking those
yeah
and yeah he's looking great
yeah
much more aggressive than the first game
very aggressive yeah we're just talking
about his defensive style but look at
this
he's pressing forward
all the hits
running three again
oh gets the walls flat and this is
looking awesome right now
this is beat down all right jd with the
block here
wow two rounds
stopping every down four
oh that's stuck there yeah jd's been
ducking that all day
yeah
there is the full punish on the floor
nicely done
yep
hey
jdcr running away with this round
invested in rage oh scabs here
[Music]
good block delayed hot cake putty yeah
yo jd
you're so ready for that oh man
i can't do those
all right still going low and faster
oh what a beautiful whip punish there
great spacing
the small stage is gonna get jdcr
very close to the wall here he rolled
forward
break it oh god
jdcr does not want to deal with that
guard break mix-ups
he's got to move or hit a button or
something get out yeah he moved yeah
both players keeping this very slow yo
compact yo they're just very intense
literally
sometimes
final
great positioning for it kdc alright
[Music]
too far breaks at all break the shining
wizard what
[Music]
he's so tense
he's going to be able to finish jd
oh
wow
damn
what a comeback
yeah he was behind two zero rounds in
that game right he turned it all around
there nicely done jdcr you know
historically i've never really been a
big fan of jd's army i told him this i'm
not like to talk to trashbandage back he
knows this but i'm impressed today i'm
impressed today this is this is very fun
to watch his armor king is really really
sick right now uh and defensively all
the the decisions he's made and the
punishes have been on point uh even the
one delay hopkins punish he had at the
end of the round when you don't even
need a delayed hopkins you don't have to
do that uh like
you don't have to do that you just do a
while standing for no delayed hopkins
the punish i do on this you know when i
block it sends a message just really
well played super big message and two to
zero now gets the [ __ ] rom now you
mentioned infested also has potentially
a negan to bring out uh obviously we
know jdtr has that pocket [ __ ] wrong
he's won big tournaments before with it
so he has a lot of pokemon experience
and it's really showing here uh there's
a lot of like mix-ups that focus one
throws at you then jd is not even being
phased by it's like yeah if it's the
higher the duck it's the mid i'm gonna
block it uh you know he looks like he's
had a lot of experience against this so
i'm curious here if he's actually gonna
try to switch characters because the
[ __ ] rom yeah as good as it looked at
the beginning of the second game doesn't
look like it's gonna be able to get it
done to me
you know
yeah be interesting to see what invested
does he is down too this is a very tough
situation he's sticking uh with the
fakum rum here uh
yeah same stage yeah
yeah this is such an uphill battle right
um being down 2-0 like this but uh
infested you know uh we'll see what he
has
if you can make it right and [ __ ] with
the wrong game you can take the momentum
yeah pokemon can definitely do it right
yeah the thing is you just know that
defensively it's gonna be difficult
against what you can't get away with
everything you get away with against
everyone else because jd defense against
character is so much better than
everyone else has been look at that he
committed that duck he's like oh
jeffy aren't you this is the range you
want to do it
oh dude that jab was sick oh my god that
jab
yeah
oh but you know best it does have to
live in here it's pretty cool oh never
mind this is
the only lights out that wall yes
yes
oh yeah
armadillo looking so small combo damaged
looking so strong right now impenetrable
defense
[Music]
oh my gosh
wow this is everything
[Music]
look at you he's standing there
i mean that's not the room not afraid
general right they're both in each
other's face
yeah oh perfect spacing punish their jdc
are looking so dominant
wow
this is round yeah this is looking like
it's going to be a 3-0 infested
need to make something happen here
oh
and he was blocking a lot of those
not anymore
yeah what was that that looks like input
oh
yeah big accidental jump but here comes
the combo from jd here
wall carry bing bang boom
what's the mix-up
oh trade here getting started enraged oh
oh he's still alive
last chance infested stay on the inside
of the bracket here get out of here
moving on to the grand finals with the
arm king three to zero over infested
it's like hey kid you've had a good run
john ding
knee
cherry berry mango
not jdcr i'm staying off the list right
now
right
yeah i'm staying off this for now for
now in fact it's still in the turn of
course jdc are moving on to the winner's
side of grand finals but let's take a
look back at some of the action here the
unblockable tech has something he's been
going to quite a bit
uh in in and around situations right and
this multi-throat did not work out not
gonna damage yeah i thought he could see
i thought it would would have been
enough yeah but didn't quite do it oh
yeah that's why he interrupted yeah he
tried the attempt there but
uh jdcr2 ready stops it
and here's all the pokes and just you
know smothering it invested brought it
back it made it look interesting right
it looked like okay wait there's still
hope here uh maybe a little bit of fall
soap at least but this there right there
you know j-star going for that local
stop but you know investor went for the
the big mid uh counter yeah he didn't
find the counter of course
and that was jd's delayed hopking full
combo punches here it goes up 2-0 and
investor had the opportunity to switch
characters sticks it out with focus
believed in his choices
uh but unfortunately you know jdcr he's
a monster and i think it really looks
like his time with fakamrom
has really paid off because now
defensively against the character he
looks super sharp yeah and uh
and yeah this is the thing about the the
longer side i mean you can see how how
much of a read that jdcr had against
infested uh that game and um you know it
was a 3-0 but it was it just it just
seemed like he was getting more and more
dominant and that culminated into him
blocking that low at the end and being
able to finish it off but yeah i mean if
you look here we don't have a very many
players left we have jdcr in the grand
finals just waiting comfortable there in
winners invested in losers finals uh
waiting there waiting to play the winner
of saint versus cherry berry mango uh
for the losers final final match uh so
yeah the next game that we're gonna have
is saint
general gaming saint versus africa
freaks cherry berry mango should be an
interesting match i'm thinking ganru
versus jin is that i don't think he's
gonna blast like
his lars i think that was like a one
time thing i think you just want to show
up
or something but
like hey did you um lars can take it
from this stage to the other yeah you
know like yeah cool huh all right back
to gym you know gonna be known as a
maine forever uh but yes this should be
an extra matchup saint has been playing
fantastic today the gander you you know
getting into top four obviously we all
know yeah
always stacked always very difficult to
even make the top eight uh and here
saint is all the way to the top four and
i brought it up earlier but the reason
santa didn't lose a bracket is because
he lost to eye musician but i musician
did not make the top eight so all the
players in the top eight have not beat
saint today you know that's the way it
goes so yeah uh saint has a unique
opportunity here uh just to have this
clean run and doesn't deal with any kind
of double jeopardy situation
uh so it's gonna be very very very
interesting here and gandhi versus jyn
in tekken 7 i have not seen that match
up yet uh very curious to see how that
one goes um
but like i was saying earlier i feel
like everybody knows gam you just kind
of like how everyone knows jack like
things don't really change that was the
end game to get a couple new tools here
and there but overall the core the
character stays uh but at the same time
uh the way saint plays it is pretty
pretty good like you know it's all about
the mind game right and saying oh yeah
mind game master
yeah yeah he's definitely you know he's
had those runs where he's just you know
harassing the downfall three and uh yeah
just pops him with the the downpour too
just at the right moment like almost
like exactly like you'll do he'll do it
like four times in a row he'll uh he'll
chase someone down and trying to back
dash and uh just
just
get some of the right ones like every
time he's just uh so successful with it
and uh of course against cherry barry
mango who's been uh electric king
everybody uh with his conscious so
that's true we're gonna see a lot of
those
yeah in this i wonder if we will though
i feel like yeah maybe he might be the
kind of player
where if you're gonna do electrics then
he's gonna be like all right i know
you're electric king i'm gonna launch it
i'm gonna duck it and watch it everyone
talk about how hard yeah
yeah he can do that oh wait wait wait
wait whoa we got a character and stevia
he does though so this is actually legit
pocket character he he has played i
remember quite a bit right and uh
yeah so this is interesting i mean i
mean noctis has like crazy you know
rule-breaking range right in uh in
tekken with some of these attacks and uh
maybe he feels that he can just outrange
uh
and frustrate saint here
fight yeah let's see how it goes you're
the knock this pick coming out of cbm
here oh
yeah
face tab
yeah that's what imagine obamacare i
just wonder i imagine it like in the uh
final fantasy like move name with you
know like what happened
oh yeah there's another one again
there's another face tab there
ow
yeah that counter hit those two
into a belly spirit
i definitely think cherry berry mango is
taking this character because he feels
confident about this matchup but he is
at the wall now
trying to get out
oh yes
anytime you see the downforce we come
out you know saints getting in the group
yeah yeah
man this looks really annoying to deal
with the four four one plus two finds
its mark here
wow throw attempt
class i'm coming at him yep
and that'll be
that round
this is very interesting
yeah now what are we expecting right
a lot of damages and cbm can't load
period either so that's uh that's an
interesting
strategy here because you know it says
this guy who likes back dash and like
swift punch you uh what do you do about
those downstairs yeah
yeah
nicely done
round four
yeah what
[Music]
oh nice invasion on that uh projectile
he has cherry berry mango i think he's
trying to
kind of keep him out but saint has still
been able to get in
and start his mix-ups
yeah
not this time
oh okay nice block here
dude i'm just out of range i feel like
yeah
i can't believe we even got the clap
after that he's down to whip and he got
the full forward clap on him very hard
to do saint
solid first game the the knock stick
looked kind of interesting at first but
i don't think so
yeah yeah i mean he got he got a couple
of space stabs uh of course countering
couple based out
yeah i think he just wanted to kind of
um take advantage of his range but just
it didn't happen he just got in and did
down down four threes and down four twos
and you know got stuff going anyways so
i don't know if he's going to stick this
this character
yeah and like i was missing it's only
first to two here this is losing semi
files this is not the loser final of the
tournament right so uh picking out you
know pocket character choice like this
like you gotta have a pretty good just
uh reason for that right like your
decision making on that has to be on
point and
uh it look it looked like it wasn't
terrible choice at first but
uh overall it doesn't work out so now
he's in a a little bit of a pickle right
he's either committed to knock this the
whole way or he's gonna have to switch
over the gin uh and that's the reason
that i don't like playing multiple
characters in tournament you know i just
want to stick to the one and know what
i'm dealing with you know you don't have
to second-guess yourself between matches
you don't got to rethink strategies
halfway through you're just sticking for
him like all the way through so
let's see what he decided
all right
all right he's sticking with it yeah
yeah
oh yeah he got uh he got his stage
here
uh
yeah match the character to the stage
i'd like probably give you some kind of
buff right i don't know
you would hope so
taking them home
yeah a lot of case players you choose
howard to stay and here we go
this is that game two saying up one game
best of three
hey
that counter hit
oh no downpour one for you i'm gonna be
out of range
yeah exactly that's the thing right
same is so good at judging your
character's range look at these
two yeah that was so successful
oh that's the second time he's done that
yeah
side switch
oh okay burns his
rage
no duck on the iphone
behind did you even believe it what the
hell on the side oh yeah just tried for
counters like no no no no no
oh big with there no punish
[Music]
man just duck me others faces right now
stay down
success rate so high with that
the wall
mix up oh
damn stay there oh okay
oh okay here we go the weapons are
coming out
yeah
danny's not [ __ ] after you down once
i think that's the first time we saw
that
very linear move
boy if he had punished that right there
he could have backed that down for two
caught him stepping oh
another down two could close it out here
mix up with four four plus two maybe
slightly out of range
oh
yeah so strong this tournament oh
headbutt nice very fast move
that was weird
yeah okay guess the wall splat here
oh the pickup
the same
range if he can survive
he was like backwards dude what
yeah that was just though terry brady
mango recognize the situation that was
very smart with him right there yeah
but overall
uh oh my goodness the throws that was
crazy
look at the damage oh my god
oh my god perfect see you later with the
perfect that was perfect that was
perfect saint
yeah just continuing his his streak
right now he's just been
yeah he's been on a tear
uh he's been so successful with his uh
his downforce everything working um able
to get his pressure um able to just be
in that right uh position right amount
of space um that's everything is doing
is working i think and yeah genuine
gaming saying moving on to the top three
of the tournament nice try for cbm that
goes out of fourth place it's very
impressive gets a ton of points for that
of course uh the points obviously are
all gonna matter right because you need
those points to get into the top eight
the top eight will move on to the
regional finals uh so that's points
there for cbm gonna be pretty important
here uh because a lot of money on the
line and here you see the leaderboards
uh that is for the
oh man that oceania you know oceana
oh how do you
that was their leaderboard all right
korea has their own leaderboard and
that's what they're going to make into
their week i can't say the damn word oh
shina oceana oceana oceana so she is
okay now i'm doubting myself now i think
i'm thinking it's the way that you said
earlier and all right i say like
encyclopedia you know yeah forget about
it here's the points that we had coming
into this right so there you see me
first place uh male 1 uh at 25 miles you
can see there's not many points look at
look at seventh place there are zero
points on here so yeah if somebody were
to run a dojo event
even a small 16-man one someone could
crack into the top eight you know yeah
it's like that right now uh and steve's
mom is dana like i don't know about that
but
you know somebody could knock out
dana or steve's mom you know yeah it's
possible just for the points here at
this event
i i what what does that even mean
steve mom is
staying i steve i don't know maybe maybe
dana i don't know dana yeah
oh she anna oh she anna williams i got
it okay
hey you guys are hooking me up
n a education in full effect uh we also
got some sick shirts for you guys if you
guys haven't keep a note
uh yeah i got the we got your shirt here
nina williams paul phoenix marshall king
i do have the paul phoenix when i have
the black one the good ass techno shirt
actually it is one of my favorite shirts
um i also got sent actually got a leroy
uh shirt as well there's leroy and sugar
i got the one uh yeah i also got the
black one i need ones with colors uh
there's nina and anna and there's all
this and i know this is a cute cute ass
tekken this is very very cute shirt um
limited edition pre-order now uh make
sure to go to 10-0 gd merch to get that
sweet sweet merch and uh but yeah this
one's discontinued though this is what i
heard so it's sold out is what it is so
that oh you guys have gone to the
website you'll see
these shirts sell out yeah so get a
while you gotta keep up if you're
interested and i've talked about in the
past you know
there's not a lot of tech and merch out
there right so get it while you can
because you're going to miss your
opportunity essentially right
of course you guys want to keep up to
date with all the tech and stuff make
sure you guys follow all these channels
on your socials you got bne esports on
both twitter and on youtube plus you got
tekken on twitter twitch and on facebook
as well so make sure you guys go out
there give them all if you guys are
watching this right now to wherever
you're watching it click that follow
button i know there's a bunch of people
restreaming as well click the follow
button up there and give some
subscriptions whatever uh but right now
we do got to take a short break guys
don't go anywhere when we come back
we'll have our top three for technology
2021 from korea
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace
once lost
the golden order is broken
to its core
[Music]
[Music]
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
they will fight
and they will die
in an unending curse
to be born
well
[Music]
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
brandish the elden ring
for all of
us it's not just our power
it's all about powers working as a team
don't underestimate me here goes
be prepared for anything
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take it
back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
they're gone
we came to save you
you won't be getting out of here alive
even the smallest of sparks can grow
into an inferno i must give precedence
to the task at hand snuffing out your
fire before it spreads across the five
realms
i think you can cut me down
what
those with power set the example
and those without it are forced to obey
i found you at last and i see you came
along as well
dan and witch
i thought i had been doomed to a life of
solitude that doesn't mean i'm going to
stop looking out for you not now not
ever
everyone be careful that thing is huge
[Music]
tectonic vision
this
[Music]
dan in is and the renaissance
looks like we've got our work cut out
for us
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you are watching the tekken
online challenge master event for the
korea
region we are down to three players we
have jdcr in the grand finals waiting
for the winner of the losers final match
of rocks infested and genuine gaming's
saint so
uh rip well what do you think's gonna
happen are we gonna get uh
a 2017
match uh in the grand finals echo fox is
coming back together they're picking up
uh they're picking up jdc ransom they
take away from genuine gaming uh it
could happen it really might but we'll
see this is it's very rare to see saint
and jcr doing this well in tekken 7
again right like it's been years and
years and years since that happened
right so hopefully that's what happened
that's what i'm i think or what a lot of
people watch are probably rooting for
but don't forget guys keep checking on
towns brought to you by astro the
official headset and mix app of the
tekken online challenge 2021. i got the
six speaker tags on here they say tekken
online challenge on which is probably
pretty rare right like these are
probably like limited edition and you
can only find them on my head uh you
know i'm sure there's probably a couple
other people in the world who have them
but uh very cool stuff thank you very
much astro for supporting these tekken
online challenge events
uh because without them you know this
stuff wouldn't be as crazy as this two
thousand dollar prize pool here uh for
these players that are in this top four
jdc are sitting there winning side grand
finals waiting for from losers final
infested or saint uh of course cbm going
out at fourth place here today uh points
on the line of course all these players
trying to get into that
regional finals the regional finals of
course will be a six thousand dollar
prize pool so a lot of money available
in these online players uh in his online
terms for these players
yeah and uh yeah basically i think um i
think it's a two thousand dollar prize
pool for this tournament so uh i think
first place uh saving fifty percent i
think second place is gonna get um
uh
it's like 20 or something so i think
it's gonna be like an 800 money match in
the the grand finals but uh
uh yeah it should be should be pretty
crazy i don't know it's kind of fun to
kind of you know put it that way
sometimes but of course yeah especially
when it's just like yeah these guys are
at home playing for hundreds of dollars
in this online match of tech like wow
where did that come from you know
online challenge right the crazy thing
is obviously we've been doing this
around the world right throughout so
many regions uh and it's just it's so
crazy because if you go back to when the
tech world tour started you know kind of
just like oh we're gonna go to these
countries whatever like this europe you
get you get a five player you know na
you get five players you get five
players we're gonna have a tournament
afterwards and then they they expanded
like oh now we have tournaments across
the world you guys gotta travel to get
your points whatever uh you know and
then all of a sudden they're like all
right well now we're just saying points
anyone from anywhere can qualify it's
like whoa uh you know this will be full
of korea and japan but didn't happen
that way either right uh so it's just
been so interesting and now with tekken
online challenge you know obviously with
travel being restricted we have more
regions around the world than have ever
been represented you know we've seen
players from around the world uh
competing who we never thought or who
never had the opportunity to go to these
other tournaments before now have a
chance to compete uh in front of the
world at tekken channel officially right
so very very cool stuff here with the
tekken online challenge 2021 this year
and i can't wait to see what they decide
to do next year for 2022.
yeah
well uh we right now we do have uh a
rocks infested versus uh genuine gaming
saint uh match coming up um you know
very strong players infested made a uh
so far has made an amazing run only
losing to
jdcr and winners to uh get into losers
final but um you know he he ran a train
over uh a bunch of strong players knee
junting um
cherry berry mango here in the top eight
and uh now he's in the loser's final and
then uh of course saint another player
who's you know with his gyneroo uh has
made it very far right now potentially
going into the grand finals to meet uh a
former teammate jdcr uh we'll have to
see
who uh who takes this match
to get there all right
this is losers final of the tournament
genuine gaming saint going up against
infested here uh and of course invested
in that [ __ ] worm saint has been picking
dragon's nest when it's his opportunity
to pick but this time to get it on
random so a little bit of luck on the
same side here this is losing finals so
we'll be first to three games
game on round one
right
things
this is best of five
first three so have a long set here
oh
three of them
we could have done that again
oh why do it again when you run up and
down for two the next time
oh man dude
still on its hair
it seems like such a simple game plan
right
like yeah i'm just gonna down forward
three and down forward one hey chad
y'all do it too
yeah i want some back dash cancels with
them
and you're right that deceptive range is
it's actually really useful for this
match where he's fighting against the
you know [ __ ] mom's three
so long that's true right now state at
the wall though
trying to fight his way out
extremely turtle and extremely
aggressive against jdc at least when he
was falling behind
when the total gameplay wasn't working
out so so far you know i'm kind of a mix
between the two going against here
oh nice
oh yeah yeah
yeah there we go
down four two three i believe minus
eleven right uh on block so if you don't
duck the second hit because there is a
little bit of a mix up there you still
get a punishment
yeah
saint
good start to this round oh and the
class has a little punishment wow clap
pointing for the jet kick that was tight
infested is looking like his gas tank is
running low right now you know he needs
to refuel uh you know he
he used his whole tank to get past me
and john ding and cherry berry mango got
to jdcr and he was like just starting to
run out of gas like oh
out of gas right uh so right now he's
got he's got to figure something out
because you know he's lost
four games in a row now three straight
to jdtr and now one the same so it's
not looking pretty
yeah the only moments that he was able
to get anything started was when he was
able to bully uh saint into the the
corner at the wall and he was able to
keep some pressure there but i just feel
like um saint's just able to fight his
way out and uh and start his mix-ups and
uh yeah he's just getting uh yeah
everything's still working for saint you
know it's
you know it's still there so we'll see
if uh we do have uh more games uh
against infested this is best of five so
yeah
and maybe maybe we will see a negan
i would i wouldn't mind could be
i mean if he loses this next game i feel
like he's got to try negan after that
but
it's going to be [ __ ] wrong i'm still
here and you know the character focus
he's fine right he's got the options to
do everything yeah um yeah and the
offensive strategy from saying it's it's
straightforward it's simple right uh but
defensively he's playing fantastic right
and that's what's separating things here
uh whether defense can keep up
with infested's offense
and so far so good
twilight conflict so switching things up
here too right uh we've seen him go to a
bunch
yeah that'll go for the balcony of the
stage
yeah got a balcony break it also that's
true
man looking for the timing on the
downpour too that's such a jack player
yeah thing to do
oh out of here
there you go
oh wow other side oh
yeah just switch sides like that
oh
invested now
doing what [ __ ] rums do
uh he's such a deficit now is
i need something in that movie i'm
talking about yeah so fast great with
punish
yeah and the follow-up damage can land
at a wall you know it's yeah
ridiculous
that move probably needs to be adjusted
look at that see it's launch punch who's
doing it you know yeah yeah everyone's
just doing
so fast
at the wall
oh
threatening heartbreak
you have to punch with gander with
canned perry which would be pretty tight
too right
here
he doesn't have the page
blocks yeah
really yet he wow the launch stayed are
you gonna clutch out this round two oh
my god hell yes he is
four
fight all right
same with the clutch block and down
downforce all day he's like man your
downforce are so annoying i'm just my
down four all day
i'm gonna do it back to you he's
literally trying to play the same game
back at him right yeah
he's like it's like getting to him
oh
no no doubt this is my game
against infested this is yeah saints
momentum is great i'm actually worried
if he if he wins this like hey jdcr
probably noticing this this momentum
that that saint has
i mean it's
it's crazy i just feel like nothing can
stop him right now at this point
at the same time you say that though i
feel like
jd is probably watching and laughing you
know i feel like he's like that's not
going to work and me you know like of
course he's going to do it there like he
knows saints so well both of them know
each other so well
uh so i mean
it seems like that's where we're headed
right it seems like saints gonna run
through
infested right now he's going to make
him jdcr we're going to get a classic
2017 match in 2021 out here
but the fest is not done yet right the
pokemon now o2 invested his own five
since reaching the winners final so yeah
he needs to change something it might be
a character switch time maybe not but
really right now i don't know if it's
even gonna matter because the offense
from saint is what's winning him
everything right like defensively his
defense is always there anyway but the
offense is just a downpour three down
for one of the downfall twos especially
the dow for two game from saint is
really what's turning things around here
yeah against everybody
yeah and
yeah he's definitely been able to crack
through infestes uh investors defense
and we were talking about how strong his
defense was how patient of a player he
was but it doesn't matter because yeah
saints just getting in there and
frustrating him and uh
you know tagging him with lows whenever
he wants however he wants
getting to his head all right
yeah infested has to make something
happen here he's down uh
two games
nice back dash
that's gotta be [ __ ] around the whole
way huh
yeah infested not being able to
capitalize on on his frame advantage
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
yeah the last part is yeah could this be
a chance for investors to make some
adjustments
oh an interrupt three one today you
wanna throw those things on me
he was so ready for that oh i'm now at
the wall oh look at that he wants to
duck there he ducked that jumping bomb
he gets three headbutt walls flat
oh my god
oh man the crumple yeah
we infested this eager there
the attack
message with rage though
oh but saint doesn't care just
pushes on takes that round
fight
i think downfall is guaranteed there oh
you were just talking about downpour two
games
yeah how is it working
yeah fight
infested
last chances
ah but no no no conversion from that he
clapped his toenails or something dude
that was crazy yeah yeah three of them
yeah
oh man and you're saying like he's been
just being offensive but like yeah he
has his defense to pull it out whenever
he needs
okay
and he knows that it makes up the time
to punish daddy look at this block and
headbutt punish
and that's the man oh my god he tried to
unblock him
makes it at the grand finals to face
jdcr and winners
what what
yeah that's a that's a great way to
to end the the game i mean just like
yeah the ultimate call out right just
his foot was like right and he was like
smelling his foot when he did that that
radar it was so clean just barely just
all of it it's just perfect spacing
perfect spacing oh yeah steve's playing
pretty good today you know if you're jcr
uh and you're laughing back there you
may have to be a little bit cautious
just that's awesome yeah so that's
really really good
yeah and um this is the thing like i
guess infested's uh streak was kind of
you know um
put to a stop with jdcr in winter's
finals right so is jdc are going to do
this again you know saint has been
having this crazy streak right now and
this jdc are just going to is it going
to be another 3-0 like he did to
infested and you know it's just like no
you know things just stop here at jdcr
so the wall is jcr like
historically when these guys have played
it's it's gone kind of one-sided
sometimes right uh sometimes you've seen
it completely one-sided jcr sometimes
the other way completely one side is
saying other times it starts off one
when it goes backwards it's really
unpredictable and you know now that the
character matchups are so different like
we know this match for 2017 is jack
versus dragon off right and everyone's
like boo those characters we've seen
enough of them
and then they nerfed them and then
finally like four years later they
buffed them again and these guys aren't
playing those characters right uh
they've got gan wii u and arm king right
now it's probably what we're going to
see
and yeah from jd as i was saying earlier
i'm liking it you know which is
something i haven't said about his arm
king in the past uh but i think his arm
king is looking really good right now
and on the other hand you've got saint
with his classic ganryu which he's
playing ridiculous right uh hi and he's
gandhi with the way he's playing right
now it's very reminiscent of his jack
from back in the day but let's take a
look back some of this action from satan
effect a second ago i mean it was
totally one-sided right completely
saints is dominating uh and you know
there's small opportunities here this
was one that same gave to him by these
given
but even after he gave them right you
still have this crazy finish and the
clap out of nowhere yeah like why do you
have a pixel e
clap
craziness yeah
yeah invested had some moments there uh
for sure but i mean i i would say saint
just uh had the read in this matchup
completely and was able to uh just you
know outspace him uh that down forward
too uh you're talking about just you
know working almost every single time
yeah and uh yeah and yeah it was just
yeah
it's not one of those moves that's like
a broken move right it's it's not like a
leroy orbital or you know a mart attack
or something where it was like dude that
move is so good you know it's just a
normal town for two that's really far uh
and it's punishable it's got options
after it but at the same time just
saying hit rate but it's so crazy good
like the saint himself was so good not
the character's move you know uh which
is what makes it so special to watch
yeah but look at that pressure off the
jet kick and he just claps right after
dude
sam playing really really well right now
yeah it makes me wonder that you know if
he can bring this into the next match
and of course this was the uh the clutch
rage art where he
basically was just out of range uh and
uh yeah pulled the trigger at the right
time and
and
yeah this
that that's how you end off uh a game
like that that you're dominating you do
you do something crazy like that or or
block a low hell sweep or something or
something sick right i mean that's when
you
hit the ramp
definitely like he was so confident
about it right going into it because
right forward he tried the unblockable
setup and then he hit him with the rager
like he was trying to style he's like
like i got this is over you know it's
done but of course guys this is the last
match event weekend right so you guys
been keeping up this schedule today is
korea tomorrow is japan right so that's
going to wrap up the online master event
so we went through all these regions
around the world but then starting up in
november we will have the regional
finals events starting from south africa
working our way through the whole planet
again and ending in north america
january 9 2022 so make sure you guys are
tuning in for all those events uh as
players of course you know you don't
have a lot of chances left to make
points obviously if you need some dojo
points to try to squeeze in there the
doji applications are ending october
10th right so you've got like one day
for this already so that's it and of
course you guys are players make sure
you're registered ready the website is
there for you it's at the bottom with
another screen that we showed you last
time although at this point it's already
passed october 8th so it was too late
you had dinner you didn't so you're done
or you're good uh but yes if you guys
want it make a dojo adventure left time
to do that so go and submit your claim
right now if the players want to be
involved in that in your region
and of course got good ass tekken shirts
yeah sorry yeah yeah we got nina
williams paul phoenix martial law king
uh in different colors good ass tekken
uh i got the the black paul one uh one
of my favorite shirts definitely and uh
we have these cute ones with uh leroy uh
nina anna king armor julia chang this uh
yeah there's like these are the
the cute series i guess uh we have the
kuni mitsu here you guys tekken uh just
go to ten o uh ten dash o dot gg merch
and uh you can find uh you can find
these shirts on sale don't miss out
don't decide this got sold out this
shirt was so good it took me this that's
what happens to any of those might get
sold out you got to buy it gotta go when
it's hot
exactly
but coming up guys we get the classic
right it's going to be genuine gaming
sink versus jdcr grand finals of the
tournament just like the good old days
right
uh wow a little bit different
no no they're split up now they're no
longer teammates yeah no jack no dragon
although wouldn't that be wild can you
imagine if they did that like their
grandfather yeah
i'm picking jack let's do this oh man
i don't know
i don't know there could be some hype
with that i remember during that time
they were both so dominant that um those
two characters were just like oh man why
does this game have so much uh you know
dragon off and jack like well these two
players are just being so dominant
during that time right and uh right yeah
so to see them together like this
there's some nostalgia factor that you
can't huge i think so yeah of course and
you know i think you know back then i
remember a lot of people thought like
well they're kind of the first the first
cruisers are traveling around for these
tekken events coming all across north
america of course they're gonna win you
know so of course you see dragon off and
jack and you know it was fun because
everyone's trying to beat them right
like you knew they were the big targets
and everyone trying to take them up but
you couldn't uh so it was a lot of fun
back then but of course as the tour
progressed you know they weren't the top
two anymore because so many other people
from around the world were also
traveling to all these master events
right so as the tour progressed you know
they kind of fell off a little bit but
at the same time now you're looking at
it there's a bunch of queens in this
event and they're still in the grand
finals different characters it's tight
this is a super cool story line it's
kind of like a retribution arc except
there was nothing
to
retribute
yeah
yeah yeah you don't know about that but
but here we go i know what you mean
though grand
finals
it's gonna be saint versus jdcr jdc are
sitting on the winner's side of the
bracket and the characters are going to
be armor king versus ganryu
that this i i can't say i expected this
uh i never thought it'd be an
impossibility but definitely an
unexpected grand finals here um but yeah
uh saint has to win twice against jdcr
which is
difficult for anyone
round one
fight
maybe not so difficult for staying
listen down four two oh start the grand
finals first thing he does
yep
i'm gonna send a message
over half off right now oh how about
that
i know you're gonna do that low here's a
hot
yeah and these two players know each
other really well this is you know
people who know each other well play
different
look at this this is so yeah
this is slugfest
this is violent oh
yes
gets the first round he gets his dance
right after
what
yes it said
return to sender
oh just uh staying back jdc art
pulling back a little bit
i know this is respect or slowing it
down okay here we go
are you is this going to kill are you
that's like a 75 life oh my god with
conroe
oh my will it kill
what was that he's laughing my god
he's gotta be laughing at i don't think
i don't think jd starts laughing right
now this is not the killer jdtr face
dave just laughing
say
yes
oh man
dude jd sure had like a 90 lead that
round that was so crazy
yeah that was the same
another huge leap for j.d
he does it again again he does another
backswing blow combo here oh raise drive
this time and jd is walking for us there
fight
no
this is great
hope for pogba not finishing the string
this time
oh god he read the clap dude
yeah knew it
didn't get that wall damage here and
jdcr saying
that round was cute but
i'm still here
yo this tekken is crazy yeah
you're really going at it
oh
you guys would punish
jcr
looking to take this round but
say wait
oh wait
here that's going to be punished yeah
wow yeah final round game one
fight
oh
nice wave away boo
oh god
yes realized
that's how you want to close it out jdc
are getting the first game here with the
perfect at the end that was back and
forth the whole way through though that
was not easy for either player that was
tight
whoo that was a great game yeah i know
good ass tekken started sweat
yeah where's the shirt right i mean this
is this is crazy jdcr is uh he stopped
infested you know after his hot streak
is this jdcr saying to saint right now
it's is this like no i'm gonna i'm gonna
stop this here i'm gonna three oh this i
don't wanna get even close to a reset uh
you know is this a message or is saint
you know is this has he finally met you
know an opponent that can uh make him
think twice about going in and just down
forward three and like five times in a
row right
i think he knows what he can and cannot
get away with against jdcr right just in
terms of mind games like this right jars
played his jack a billion times he knows
the kind of mind games that saint wants
to use with these lows and mid mix-ups
uh and like even the duck in that clap
from out of range like he did it so
perfectly he's like he's gonna clap your
watch i'm gonna make him do the clown
grip by looking juicy i'm just juicy big
you wanna do that clap don't you duck
hockey you're dead uh so we'll see if
sane can adjust here but
you can see both players have a very
good understanding of
each other right so
anything in half yeah mission madojo is
the stage that's gonna be picked here
uh and i like it i honestly
i'm sitting way closer to my monitor
than i usually do watching these guys
play each other it just feels so right
uh and just the level they play at with
each other you know it's fantastic here
we go game two
yeah definitely not holding any punches
[Music]
the convo with oh
yes
oh there's the counter one count there
you go
oh wait wait wait wait sidewalk yep yeah
that was
and the positioning he got from this is
crazy
oh you yeah
i don't care and immediately that time
it was down four three the downpour
would want to stop him uh and then
immediately doubtfully downpour three
right so smarts up the same first round
oh he got the hug oh yeah put him back
down
yeah
okay down twos
yeah got him he only did one downpour
three that time and this is
damage
yeah already two rounds
no round brown for you sir you know
nicely done same serves up jcr on the
plate of that game that was a beat down
uh and man i don't even know
what jcr did wrong there it was just
like saving everything right like
literally everything right again and
that's how sam's been throughout the
loser bracket
yeah yeah so definitely jdcr uh you know
he lost the game here i mean you know
previously jdcr uh was coming from the
winners final where he didn't lose the
game now uh yeah now things are kind of
shifted is one one uh there's a risk of
you know possibly getting reset and you
don't want to be the winners bracket guy
who gets reset on that's a that's a
mental uh mental guard break right so
um yeah saint is uh is
showing like he still has that momentum
and you know to be fair even that first
game um it was it was you know it was
kind of close it went down to the final
round you know it wasn't like a
no round brown or anything so i still
think saint does have that momentum he
just needs to adjust his play style um i
mean he's playing against somebody who
knows him so well uh
but uh he just needs to keep that
momentum of a thing
i mean i think it's very possible
that saint can win this tournament he's
playing so well today
uh yeah and obviously you know it goes
without saying either one of these guys
could win this tournament but i feel
like saint is the underdog here which is
why i'm saying it that way right
uh yeah so we'll see if you can hold on
uh that last game looks pretty
convincing but jdc are now taking us to
infinite stage
uh the wall comments from gambling have
been adding up
might be part of the factor here
oh
here's that counter hit again
jd start with a good start to this first
round
wow
that's crazy dude
it's so back and forth
oh man
three round straight two dude look how
fast those first two rounds were
[Music]
they're just swapping bodies and beating
each other you know it's crazy yeah yeah
she ran up and down for two as he dark
up her head
the mix is coming
up with the rage oh just a couple of
lows take it out no three rounds great
for you
again just going in saint not scared
went back went back in
yeah like i'm going to run away no i
changed my mind i'm going to go in and
downpour too
oh my god this is crazy dude
this is an insane match
everything starts off from the down four
three and just like this we're going to
the final round of game three yes sir he
thought it was going to be around the
way jd started it
extremely fast
look at the spacing
yeah
oh
oh there's a negative block restart yep
forget the mix i'm not letting it start
low parry
they're kind of whipping each other in
neutral right now
oh oh shining
stage movement that was so good
debatable look at this nice block he's
still ducking
he's got a huge lead though yeah yeah
he's still coming here hold on to this
yeah
satan needs to make something big happen
sir
you got me with that in game one
backswing blow with rage back turn combo
to rage are not happening again jd hit
the brakes smart stuff doesn't fall for
the backstreet blow that time
yep and that's going to make jdcr uh 2-1
right now he's going to be at a
tournament point i just need one more
game uh saint uh you know he needs to
reset the bracket if he ha if he wants a
chance to win this whole thing um yeah
but as strong as saint looked i mean
jdcr he's just you know his defense is
solid and um
you know it is kind of a slugfest right
now we hope we have to you know remember
big time it is a slugfest but um it's uh
you know
it definitely favored jdcr
uh there but um yeah i just i don't know
it's hard to know what's gonna happen
it's crazy this is
insane it's because it's almost like
they're playing rock paper scissors off
the down forward three right from gan
view yeah like are you gonna
if i hit you with down four or three are
you gonna get hit with a down four two
after is it gonna be another down four
or three am i gonna rush you yeah you
know like those are three options but
then the layers that go on top like
maybe i'm gonna back dash out and let
you whip so i can down forward to you
you know uh yeah so there's layers on
top of it so everything just starts off
with that downpour three and the final
round there you saw jd start committing
like i'm gonna block these i'm not gonna
try to low parry and like eat something
you know like i'm just gonna block it
like
personally i feel like fuzzy low prairie
is a better choice but for whatever
reason jd committing to blocks in those
situations and uh it worked out very
very well for him obviously but let's
see mission with dojo back here for
saint
jd gonna have a chance to close out the
tournament here
with the armor king the whole way
through
that's gonna be a beautiful day for
jdcr's
right tournament point for jdcr here
against genuine gaming
multi-throw time give me that one
escapes okay
yeah
wow look at this spacing dude
oh another counter hit
from jdcr
only big boy damage
just kind of like looked at each other
and stuck there a little bit of
punishment oh what was that the hop kick
yeah just looking for the hopkins was
very odd right
yeah that was pretty far
in 2017 against
genting's eddie that one that played
over and over that was wild i like reels
eight eight hey oh
he did it yeah he got what he wanted
that time
back to the wall though jdcr life
deficit getting pressure here oh look at
him and
perfect
all down for the ones that time no lows
yeah and stays in trouble
oh but he's in range right now
oh he's going to do
drive
oh jason you're going to read it
oh stop subscribing down for 1.1
tournament point for jdcr fight
js looking so strong right now saint has
to make something happen
oh that's [ __ ] there oh wow weird that
was like no punish and then like he went
up and down four shoot here
oh finished flat
all right saint looking here
trying to
try to stay alive
yeah jd's gotta raise though
say
fine try not to make mistakes like i
i mean you miss time that though you're
in like a dark up it could be bad news
but saying stays alive momentarily at
least
yeah
still tournament point for
jdcr
but saint
coming back here
little by little oh boy oh my god
oh boy
yeah
oh man of course
yeah punishment
okay
nice break important break acr yeah
okay trying to get this back i can't get
down back three i love it
oh
four two to tie it up and round final
round
still tournament point for jd
yeah you looking for that stunner kick
oh
chunky while standing fourth the
downforce is coming back now
oh jdcr way more conservative here just
on the defense looking for a moment no
counter
oh
oh
oh it's gonna hit it should be enough
damage it should be just enough damage
same with the three-round comeback it
should kill here tie it up two to two
got him save ties it up two to two
final game of the first in the grand
finals incoming
i wouldn't have it any other way damn no
not yet
not yet sustained
no it's not going to end here you all
thought it was done right i thought it
was i thought it was kind of done
that was that was impressive though man
saint is so damn good
so good
yeah
yeah and you can see like you know jdcr
at a certain point you know it was a
slugfest for a while right but then like
when he had that lead he didn't want to
like give anything away he played
definitely a bit more conservative but i
feel that uh saint just you know
capitalized on that and uh you know he
was yeah he was able to take it back
it's as i say it's 2-2 right now there
could be a reset this is
could be a reset could not be though
that's the other that's the other wild
yeah that's about it right true
yeah it feels like saints got momentum
right now but so many times in this set
itself it felt like momentum has gone
one way and then immediately shifted
back so i don't feel like momentum
is gonna tell the whole tale here in
this final game yeah but anything can
happen that's why it's so much fun to
watch these guys jdcr versus saint is
the grandfather jdc are on the winner's
side and here we go final game
of grand finals first set
we might have a tournament champion we
might have a reset
uh yeah that's very possible and oh
looks like uh yeah we're going to floor
break stage
here
oh yes forgotten well rotten realm no
one forgets the forgotten chosen by
nightwish and jdcr yes
yeah i love how so many players have
different names as they're like gamertag
you know i think
a band that he's like a finnish man like
a metal bat or something right yeah it's
a metal band yeah oh
okay looks like saint will get the first
war break here yeah you want a floor
what if i take him first
yep that's kind of the strategy against
characters who are good who can do good
damage you can take it away from them by
doing it on them first
this thunder kick the range on is why
jcr is using it so much it's so good
yeah where he wants to play with that
range
the downward one caught him falling off
the wall
fight
first round needs two more for the reset
jab jab
yeah the jab game this is not something
we've seen from the set so far yeah the
plus frame jabs bro what is this
different stance changing it up love it
yeah
yeah and oh and the clap yeah and he's
gonna get another floor break here yes
he will yeah
oh my god backwards
saint wants to reset this
he really wants to reset it
look at this crazy
oh he's in too many buttons oh my god
and this is gonna he has a floor break
here and yeah
wow he challenged and downloaded one
reset point for saint now jd's got to
make a three-round comeback oh he gets
hugged oh put him back down where are we
going to be hard in this
situation big damage from saint already
oh
to the wall bing bang boom
jiggy start step on it
oh my goodness
he got it
you got to stay solid you're saying good
luck
crazy jdcr wants his turn when he wants
to end this game
oh man
yeah the collapse
in certain ways it's not too different
from their earlier games
coming back now
yo does it
this is nuts absolutely yeah dude he did
the back two one right he this is the
first hit and immediately jade started
the counter but he only did the first he
already knew jdsr was going to try to
counter six i was like just the first
and then immediately after here's both
hits you know i was like dude yeah the
mind games are next level right here
awesome stuff same person jcr same
getting the reset which means we have
saint versus jcr
starting over one whole more grand final
set incoming
uh and i hope i hope they don't switch
characters i hope i hope it sticks this
way the whole way through because yeah
actually i like it like this yeah this
is uh this doesn't have to change and
yeah it's just oh wait
if jd does switch it'll be pretty sick
too though right yeah like it could be
very high dude
i mean i don't think he should switch
he's gandry right now it's on point
right don't touch anything but
jd like he has options if he needs to i
don't think he's going to i think he's
going to go arbiting the whole way
through i said that in the beginning of
this topic um yeah so we'll see what he
does in the sides here but
i don't know man i don't know i mean it
would be cool to see like the [ __ ]
rom or the dragon off come out i think
for me personally i think the dragon
would be the coolest one to come out
yeah
just because it's saint
yeah yeah this is uh
yeah this is a crazy match i think um oh
we got the same stage again on this this
random on-ramp yeah sure it's random
right sure it's random
superman this is a
um
round one
yeah i feel like they're just gonna keep
playing like this
yeah already it's going in
oh yeah stunner from the start
yeah oh look at this they're just
hitting each other this might be over
real fast
their speed run for sure
again they'll caught him yeah he's
catching him
what a challenge that wasn't for so much
damage
that was two of them
range right here will kill i think
yeah
oh he stuffs him and james are so good
at stuffing those oh
shoulder
what do we
that was something that he hasn't gone
to yet right like as a whiff punisher
yeah
you don't expect to eat down with
damaging whip at that range
jd with the first floor this time around
yeah
yeah
follow-up version
going downstairs no wall for you
per floor
all day no more don't do it again
[Music]
[Music]
yeah round three yeah did not fight uh
did not see that one oh
the call out
that was such a call out i don't even
know i don't know if he's looking for a
jab or what but he got the full loss in
there
we slept no
he went for the jab off the reese flat
tube didn't find it though obviously no
wall there multi-throw now
yeah get off breaks it after the first
oh
it's the pickup we're going downstairs
and is this it is this uh yep that's the
last floor saint
what what what oh it doesn't get the
follow up there oh get up three counter
hit okay
jdc are looking to
take this first game in this reset
grand final again yeah multi-throw yet
oh he just ate the third hey yeah oh it
doesn't kill though what what
oh man
if he backs and goes again dude
he's been down there all day
yeah
yeah that was that was a pretty risky
that didn't damper two to the strings
because he's been getting down jabbed
out of all of those now right jd star is
not trying to get the duck into a bigger
lodge he's taking the down jab all day
so a little rough there uh a backswing
blow there would have been crazy though
right that's that's one of those things
he's trying not to go to too much though
because obviously he worked once next
time he tried it didn't work out with jd
so
yeah it's getting very hard to make the
comebacks
yeah for sure you have so many tricks in
your bag
yeah he did he did something like
he blocked the low didn't do the punish
and then stood up and did down forward
too and it hit still i was like yeah
yeah the mind yeah the onion layers
there were like unraveling so fast i was
like which part of the audience were at
dude i've lost track yeah it's crazy
that's the thing that throws you off
because like you know when you're when
you're in the momentum of the game you
know you do you get your logos blocked
you expect you know some kind of like
punish for it and it's just you don't
expect like dash up and then pause and
then down forward and then downpour
changes
yeah
how what
yeah parts of braves malfunctioning here
yeah regardless
acr
yeah way too many jcr though up 1-0 here
in the reset grant finals hope you guys
enjoy yourself out there uh it's been
it's been a pretty crazy stack top eight
a lot of ups throughout the night but we
end up here with jdcr vs saint uh nice
nostalgic throwback for everybody
uh and here we go characters
look at these characters in grand finals
you don't see this too often oh yeah we
should make a results-based tier list
you know see if uh gaming and arcane top
here
yeah yeah seriously
oh nice
counter head against the wall
oh man
again
james you are just got to read on the
timing there
fight
hey
got him
and again here similar situation
mm-hmm
a lot more multi-throats coming out of
this set from jd
oh man you're down for two not on me
let me make you with that
jd's here already two rounds up this is
so fast
oh my god this is so painful
that's the pain this is the best
yeah jdtr his arm king i've never seen
it played this well this is yeah this is
insane this is the same he's using all
the tools that he needs to use
everything's working out
he's changing things up so effectively
and look at what the hell oh
just like that
2-0 against 2-0 this is where he's going
to 3-0
uh his opponent maybe you could be yeah
that's this is the winner's advantage
right being on the winner's side of the
grand finals this is your big advantage
like you can lose that set
but you know it's so draining on the
person who's trying to beat you just to
get the reset in the first place and
then to win an entire new sense like
beat them you did it but you gotta do it
again it's it's like it's like it's such
a mountain to climb
uh so obviously very difficult but maybe
maybe those two games you know just
say now taking that second to
recalibrate you know recognizing what's
happening he still can do it like if
anyone in the term can do it sane is one
of them right without a doubt we've seen
his tournament legacy right uh it's
possible for sure but we'll see jcr is
looking pretty good right now the down
back three counter hitting uh for him
was a surprise that's one of those moves
where i feel like jdcr typically doesn't
want to use that move he's too safe of a
player which is why i always thought
like arby's not really a good fit for
him because he doesn't want to take the
risk that this character kind of needs
sometimes but he's using now and it's
working out right so he's learned to use
these semi riskier tools which is
fantastic obviously and a lot more
multi-throws this set which has been a
big difference here uh arma key
multi-throw is very strong you got to
guess the break initially and in the
multis afterwards so it's all a guess
essentially uh but let's go jdl looking
for the 3-0 to win the tournament uh
santo has been playing fantastic all
night he could make it happen misha
madojo again same not changing it up
all right round one grand finals both
players team losers ooh the head butt at
the beginning wow what a statement
get it out gary
yeah jdcr
wall carry going to the wall
that's optimal
oh breaking that blizzard
yeah
giant swing is breaking everything out
he needs to yeah yeah yeah
doing a lot of grabs
conditioning possibly
saint with great right now here
we have that rage drafting kill here
jd's got to be careful oh nice block
we're gonna get a punish here not dead
oh what's it gonna do here
oh oh my goodness but he's gonna die oh
yeah
confirmed one
fight
holy moly
wow
all right another downpour too
and the massage this time 50 damage nice
block on the low
god
that's not even the punish anymore what
the hell
is getting focused
chad let me know
jdc rage right now though
it's still saint looking so strong
and already two rounds like this is
crazy
oh
he's going low fishing for it doing his
own lows trying to get that counter hit
still up around
actually you know he needs to win this
to
stay in the tournament
oh yeah oh look at this it's kind of
good down for it too all right real life
with the wall carry again doesn't quite
find the wall though
yeah that was beautiful
stepping on a rage
right now but this is in and out
oh
and here we go
tournament point jdcr
no no
crazy oh my god and here's the counter
head this is going to do
next oh
it's not going to do nothing
let's go
okay i don't like that no we're oh
and jdcr
takes the tournament takes tekken online
challenge master event here for korea
region
wow that was insane wow that that match
that was an insane match that what a
great way to end that we got the 2017
match
yeah
exactly jd cr the champion here tonight
same you know nice effort fantastic
games all throughout that was a good ass
tech and literally yeah that was a
stacking right there literally literally
uh why not yeah but definitely you know
jdtr first place safe second place
fantastic all around and infested coming
through with the third place finish here
today a very good job from infested took
out knee early in the tournament took
out john ding took out cherry berry
mango
and ended up in third place so i just
fell short once he reached the winner's
final the term that's a not a bad place
to fall asleep and guarantee top three
already right you're in the money so
nicely done to infest and of course
cherry berry mango rounding out the top
four of the tournaments so just crazy
stuff all around let's take a look back
here man some of the action from this
crazy grand final it was crazy
it's too many for just a replay run
no seriously they're like this would be
this replay is going to be like 20
minutes long this is awesome
for the race drive there i mean yeah i
don't even remember this is the reason
that we're silent
but uh that was a beautiful whiff punch
with the shoulder there that was
something that we hadn't seen from jd
and of course the multi all adding up
here left with just this tiny pixel uh
and it looked like maybe saint had an
opportunity but uh overall like jd was
like so confident that down jab there
he's like no no i'm just gonna keep it
as simple as possible to make sure i do
what i need to stop you and your
offensive flow
oh and then this at the wall here i mean
just everything working on jd's favor
right throughout these first couple
games
yeah
yeah the steps that came out was so nuts
oh man
oh no
no that was that was game two that this
this right here
was for game three
and yeah these rage drives weren't
working like you know jd's defense was
so bad he would like back that out and
he was always at a range where the rage
drop almost didn't even hit him
yeah well that's how he won the
tournament
blocking that range right
yeah
oh definitely if he got hit by all those
rage drives it was over right
yeah yeah but you know stay always
fighting right never let it get away
from me he's like no no i can still win
but there you go
landing what he needed to
yeah he's just saying he got those
counter hits in those situations yeah
he's just like they'll have an exchange
and that jdc will just know and and
perfectly time it that moment where you
kind of stood still for a second
[Music]
yeah oh man just just exchanged yeah
pretty much a slugfest but it was like
layers upon layers like it was like
speed chest
like real time
but this one's the end of that yeah
right here
yeah the rage drive guarantees the throw
attempt right yeah it goes for a mixture
it doesn't find that but then and that's
not enough help yep exactly checkmate
and that will be that jdcr is the
champion for the korean region of the
tekken online challenge 20 21 uh so he's
going to get a ton of points obviously
that's going to take him on to that
regional finals here is the standings
currently that will be going to that
regional files we got jdcr same infested
knee at fourth place cherry berry mango
mayo
chanel and bread man that is the top
eight for that
korean regional finals that's going to
be coming up later this year uh but of
course you know the players here if
there are dojo's events like maybe
someone can try to steal that eighth
position you know so you never really
know you know there's a one or two days
left so we'll see if that's what ends up
happening but of course guys if you guys
are wanting to keep in touch with
everything tech and make sure you guys
follow bandan ankle esports and tekken
you got bnee esports on twitter and on
youtube plus you've got tekken on
twitter twitch and on facebook so give
them a follow and stay up to date with
all things tekken and tech and esports
[Music]
yeah well uh that was uh that was an
amazing tournament and i don't think i
could ask for anything better than the
grand finals that we got here um i mean
dude we got this throwback to 2017 uh
you know
versus jdcr i mean that was just amazing
yeah but uh looks like uh we're we're
out of time here um yeah we're gonna
close it out but uh yeah any last words
uh rip uh about this turn no man thank
you guys all for joining us you know i
hope you guys had as good of a time as i
had because uh you know it's very rare
that we get to see this level of tekken
play especially what we got out of the
grand finals right so this is definitely
one of those sets that i'm going to go
back and watch in the future i'm sure a
lot of other people are as well
[Music]
all right so that should wrap it up guys
yeah that's it for us here today
technology 2021 from korea i'm rip
that's gerald and we'll see you guys
next time
have a good one peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign